hormones are the literal signaling
molecules that will communicate amongst
your organ systems that give signals of
what to do for your health
super Geeks assemble because today we
weigh deep into the weeds of science
hormones and health with Kyle Gillette
MD many people have noticed that there
is an epidemic of hormone pathology so
obesity and its related pathologies like
metabolic syndrome are extremely common
and many Physicians do not treat these
conditions at all Kyle is a dual board
certified physician and family medicine
and obesity medicine as well as an
expert in optimizing hormone levels to
improve overall health and well-being in
both men and women achieving Optimal
Health is kind of like standing at the
top of a quick sand pit and the digging
out of the quicksand or the walking on
top of it that is learning the lifestyle
interventions but you can't throw a
shovel at someone that's sinking and
expect them to get out in this
wide-ranging conversation we cover the
key role hormones play and our overall
health
and how we can leverage Kyle's six
pillars to optimize Hormone Health the
six pillars the first two are diet and
exercise and then your stress
optimization sleep sunlight and then you
have spirit it's a fascinating and
stimulating conversation I think you're
gonna dig it so without further Ado this
is me and Dr Kyle
[Music]
uh super nice to meet you Kyle thanks
for doing this I really appreciate you
coming over here to spend some time with
uh me today we're going to get geeky
can't wait for it but I want to start
with just a little bit of your your
background I mean you're a young man
what are you like 31 32 32 32 right
practicing out of Kansas like where did
this whole
um Fascination maybe borderline
obsession with human health and human
optimization where did that begin and
how did that arise I think it stemmed
from my childhood education I was
homeschooled and I noticed that a lot of
individuals for example Ben Greenfield
is also into homeschooling but it allows
you to explore a lot of things that are
not part of the norm to discover your
unique eclectic self
but I began to realize that I wanted to
go into medicine when I was in high
school and I kind of structured my
education in order to do so so you were
homeschooled throughout like your entire
academic career up until College correct
right but you went you went to college
and then you went to med school you
didn't homeschool your way through
college no I don't think you can do that
yeah yeah that's really cool I mean we
homeschooled our kids when they were
younger and then at a certain age all of
them said we want to go into normal
school so I have you know quite a bit of
experience with that my sense is that
um
it's it's really well served when the
young person does feel directional in
what they're interested in and it sounds
like you kind of had that early on which
could really drive the focus of what you
were immersing yourself in
yeah I think it would have been very
difficult I think I would have done very
poorly in a Traditional School why is
that
I tend to get on these tangents or
obsessions for example Health
optimization and then I'm really
interested in athletic performance or
cognitive performance or just like the
metaphysical and I concentrate on that
rather than whatever happens to be on
the agenda or schedule right in your
case though your dad is a doctor yeah so
you had that in the household
yeah my dad is also a family doctor and
he delivers babies kind of does full
spectrum medicine there are still many
physicians in Kansas that do so and in
the midwest in general and I saw that he
was also it was very rewarding uh I
think he finds a lot of purpose in it
and that was part of wanting to go into
medicine as well because of the the
immersiveness of it because you're
really working with families and young
people throughout the you know sort of
course of their life as they progress
right there's a different kind of
emotional attachment to it yeah so that
was the impetus to get into Family
Medicine yourself and then why obesity
like why did you choose these
Specialties the most common problems are
what uh full spectrum or primary care
physician should be the best at and I've
noticed that well many people have
noticed that there is an epidemic of
obesity and it is technically an
epidemic according to I believe the CDC
and
um there is also an epidemic of hormone
pathology so obesity and its related
pathologies like metabolic syndrome and
also different hormonal pathologies like
sub-fertility or PCOS are extremely
common and many Physicians do not treat
these conditions at all so there's an
excess demand and very little Supply
yeah and those are the very subjects
that we're going to dive in today
Hormone Health metabolic syndrome
obesity Etc and just uh you know kind of
further your point about
Primary Care Medicine
it is fair to say that Primary Care
practitioners aren't really practicing
for the most part Primary Care are they
they're really practicing sort of
secondary care it's it's diagnosed and
prescribed whereas you are you know one
of the many kind of burgeoning
functional medicine holistic medicine
practitioners and as a young person that
gives me hope like I I feel optimistic
about the future because there is so
much interest
um in expanding uh you know what's
available uh
um from our from our from our Health
Care system is is your sense optimistic
as well I mean there's a long way to go
right but the fact that you can create
these clinics and they have viable
business models and you can kind of
prove that out establishes that this
isn't just doable like this is like a
really good way to establish yourself
I agree I'm also very optimistic even
looking among my colleagues uh during
medical school at the University of
Kansas or during residency
many of us not just myself used to
listen we would listen to Peter attia
and read the content that he would put
out so there is many uh many many
Physicians not just myself that are very
interested in true preventative medicine
and health optimization hmm so let's uh
let's get into Hormone Health I mean
first you know my first question to
throw to you is what is when we're
talking about health like what is is
there a difference between talking about
health in general and Hormone Health
like what is it about Hormone Health
that perhaps sets it a little bit apart
and has sort of garnered your Intrigue
hormones are the literal signaling
molecules that will communicate amongst
your organ systems
that give signals of what to do for your
health there's many things called
feedback inhibition or feedback
mechanisms that can be positive or
negative and hormones can act on these
to try to preserve your health but when
it's in a dysregulated state pathology
can occur so they're just the signaling
molecules that control all of your
health right so
it's a good place to start when you're
diagnosing someone let's look at what's
going on here right and if your hormones
are off then there really isn't a need
to analyze anything else until that's
addressed it's sort of a Top Line
and this is more from this side of my
practice that also emphasizes
integrative medicine or functional
medicine or holistic medicine whatever
terminology you want to use with it I
like to find the cause if any biomarker
is off hormone or otherwise I like to
see the cause because Perhaps it is a
benign cause and perhaps it's not let's
define what a hormone is you call it a
signaling molecule but what is it
specifically I mean I think for the
layperson when you say hormones they
think about testosterone they think
about uh estrogen you know many people
might not even know that insulin is a
hormone like there's a lot more to this
world it's a very complex world so let's
just begin with some basic definitions
here there's three main classes of
hormones or signaling molecules most
people are familiar with the first two
classes those are your sterol hormones
or your cholesterol based they have a
cholesterol backbone
androgens are one of those for example
testosterone estrogens are another one
of those for example estradiol and also
progestogens are included in there I
would also include vitamin D in that
class as a hormone as is cholesterol
based as well you also have peptide
hormones so a lot of people are I think
you know they talk about peptides
and uh culturally peptides are more
known not really as hormones but as you
know Cutting Edge treatments kind of in
the same class as PRP or stem cells but
a peptide is just a chain of amino acids
between about two and a couple hundred
so it's a a short protein and they're
also hormones so growth hormone is an
example insulin is another example of a
life-saving peptide and then you also
have hormones that are based just on
amino acids for example thyroid hormone
is based on tyrosine now we have
melatonin adrenaline prolactin growth
hormone epinephrine there's lots going
on here
yes and I would consider all those
hormones things like norepinephrine
dopamine serotonin those would all be
Amino acid-based hormones they would be
based on dopamine and then
um serotonin and melatonin are based on
tryptophan and the definition of Hormone
Health would be an appropriate balance
of all of these important hormones
across the Spectrum correct so if
somebody comes into your clinic and says
I don't feel well or maybe this thing is
off or maybe they feel fine and you want
to diagnose this person what is the
process by which you begin to get a
picture of their Hormone Health
you want to get what we call subjective
and objective information all this means
is subjective is how the patient is
feeling the biofeedback do they feel
normal and this could be their cognitive
Health it could be their focus it could
be their libido it could be their
athletic performance
and the patient is telling you that
information and then you also use
objective information for example blood
tests or Diagnostic Imaging you
synthesize the two and that's where a
lot of the practice of medicine comes in
and then you come up with a plan has
anybody ever come into your clinic and
you've you've done this panel and you
said no you're in perfect balance
like is that a myth that you could
achieve like total optimization with
this because of just the daily life
stressors and the way we live our lives
right on some level we're all
disregulated to some extent yeah there's
always more that you can do and you can
always do more digging so it's common
for a patient to say
I've had half a dozen doctors say
there's nothing else that we can test or
there's nothing else that we can do it
might be the case that there's nothing
else that insurance will cover
as a benefit but there is always more
digging that you can do if you do more
digging you will find things right and
how does this I mean maybe this is a
longer conversation that we can get into
later but
you know obviously this is going to
depend on on your your sex your age what
span of life you're in that picture and
what you have kind of come to expect is
going to change and how you optimize is
going to be different depending upon all
those factors absolutely so you can have
two individuals let's say they're
identical twins with the same genome and
depending on what their goals are or
depending on what they are trying to
achieve they could have a different plan
and that would include the lifestyle
pillars or perhaps supplements and
medications as well right so that's
probably a good place to drop the
disclaimer that although you're a
medical doctor there will be no you know
medical advice being given today this is
general information purposes only
correct and uh even when medical advice
is given it needs to be given for an
individual because it's different sure
so there's I guess the answer to all
questions is it depends sense right it
depends yeah that's always a frustrating
one right everybody wants the answer
yeah and you're the guy you're supposed
to have the answers but it's complicated
so the pillars that you mentioned let's
go through them you've divined these six
pillars uh that kind of encapsulate what
it means to you know have optimal
Hormone Health so maybe we can kind of
go through them Siri Adam
yeah the six pillars the first two are
diet and exercise and they kind of have
the
um they're the most powerful pillars if
you will and then the last four I used
alliteration so you have uh your stress
optimization so you you want to have
some effort in life you want to have
something that you're working towards
you also have sleep and that's quality
and quantity of sleep and you have
sunlight and that really just means the
outdoors it encompasses cold exposure
heat exposure even moving your body and
being exposed to the elements and then
you have spirit and that's just the
self-actualization piece on Maslow's
hierarchy of needs and everybody has
um you know spiritual or metaphysical
Health which is important because that's
what their purpose is yeah I love that
you have that as a pillar I feel like
that's something that's often overlooked
or sort of somewhat you know dismissed
on some level and I think it's really
important and I can't help but ask like
how did you divine these pillars I
assume they're evidence-based you know
premised on all the work that you've
done as a scientist but when it comes to
the spirit thing you know I think of
uh Lisa Miller's work at Yale on the
science of spirituality which I think
you probably are familiar with she's
been on the podcast but also
um you know the blue zones work like
there's a lot of uh you know just
population studies or you know anecdotal
evidence to suggest that longevity or
kind of Health long term is rooted in
someone's sense of purpose in life and
their connection to something larger
than themselves I would say listening
and learning from people who have healed
themselves
there's another mindfulness book and I
think the title is heal thyself and it's
specifically written for healthcare
practitioners
and they teach a lot of these lifestyle
um
modifications and these lifestyle
modifications are more powerful than any
supplement or medication
now the the balance to that is I also
read a lot of literature so listen and
learn and also read literature so you're
hearing anecdotal experiences and many
people have the experience of a friend
or a family member that is on a dozen
different medications and is very
unhealthy and another one who is on no
medications and who is very healthy in
fact that at the place where we were
staying I overheard a conversation of an
individual say you know I'm 70 years old
or X just an example and I'm on no
medications and healthier than ever
and often when you see that they have
already dialed in up if not all six
lifestyle pillars they have at least
dialed in the diet and exercise so those
are those are like you know on the P
they're the foundation of the pyramid
and you're around like the the Gillette
uh hierarchy of needs for hormone
optimization yeah and I I think that an
individual such as yourself has also
emphasized and
um healed yourself with a lot of these
lifestyle pillars as well just learning
it anecdotally through life yeah sure I
was curious why my my sensibility would
be that there maybe is room for a
seventh pillar which would be Community
maybe that that weaves into Spirit on
some level because it is about
connection
um but Community seems to be a big piece
especially you know as we really get old
like the the people who seem to have a
higher quality of life are the people
who really have deep connections to
family community friends and the like
yeah there probably needs to be a
seventh maybe social if we continue with
alliteration yeah but that's definitely
true where your health is deeply
connected with your loved ones around
you right
well let's let's go back and go through
diet so talk to me about the relevance
of diet with respect to hormones
specifically diet is one of the main
modifiable interventions and you can
write nutrition prescriptions as well
um but they're a little different than
cookbooks but you can write nutrition
prescriptions
and it is one of the drivers of
metabolic syndrome which I would
consider and by the way metabolic
syndrome is just the insulin resistance
increasing abdominal body fat
dyslipidemia is part of it and
pre-diabetes it's the most common cause
of low testosterone in men and also it
leads to other pathologies like and
ovulation not ovulating insulin
resistance infertility
and diet is one of the best ways if not
the best way to fix that that's why many
clinics that you see they used to have
you know endocrinologists and then
cardiologists and now they have cardio
metabolic clinics and most academic
centers because they are really
addressing metabolic syndrome sure
because metabolic syndrome from there we
see cardiovascular disease diabetes
obesity and the like right like you it's
interesting that you know we've treated
these as separate Specialties and yet
they're all rooted in this one thing
yeah that's certainly true
obviously there's no perfect diet and
you have to be careful with diet because
you can almost swing too far at the
other end where you develop orthorexia
where you're terrified of eating things
that aren't perfectly healthy there's no
good or evil Foods yeah there's
certainly foods that can be better
consumed in higher quantities than
others but the best diet is just a
habitual eating habit that can last a
lifetime that someone will adhere to
yeah I saw a a quote on your Instagram
where you said your diet isn't a diet at
all it's a lifestyle and it's
evidence-based habit formation yeah so
like elaborate on that a little bit
[Music]
um
if you do something for a long time and
you are teaching yourself the tool to
adhere to eating
then many people may have heard of
um
instinctual eating or
um you know you're eating and it's
intuitive intuitive eating and that will
work if you've given yourselves the
tools to be able to intuitively eat
right there's a there's a problematic
aspect to that like we're both smiling
right like intuitively I just feel like
I need this thing like is that a really
a a trustworthy narrator not
particularly because it could be that
the center in your brain largely it's in
the hypothalamus that regulates hunger
or not being hunger there's two centers
the anorexogenic center which is exactly
what it sounds like and the orexagenix
center which I call the hangry Center
and if those two are not balanced you're
not going to be able to intuitively
right you'll be overridden by some
craving that doesn't serve you that
you're powerless to resist yeah and
those Cravings are being driven by
hormones yeah super interesting you
mentioned orthorexia we were chatting a
little bit before the podcast I think
that that is a often ignored aspect of
the the kind of biohacking Universe of
people who are interested in exploring
human optimization through diet and
other protocols but can easily you know
sort of Shadow disordered eating behind
like I'm fasting it's intermittent
fasting or I'm doing this you know quote
unquote protocol when in truth they just
have a you know sort of a real problem
with their relationship with food
whether it's addictive or some other
symptomology
yes and I think the same can be set of
supplements many times patients have the
best intentions but they're taking three
dozen or even four dozen different
supplements and you can almost take on a
role which has been termed the sick role
from taking on
that many different supplements you're
taking uh 40 different pills every day
and it's difficult because theoretically
a lot of these can help and usually they
have been started on this by a physician
or a dietitian or they've heard that it
can be beneficial
and on one hand you agree that many of
them are beneficial but sometimes you're
taking on a bad guy role when you're
trying to pick which are least
efficacious well also you know
everything that you put in your body
like if you're taking it for some
primary
rationale there are all kinds of
secondary and tertiary Downstream
implications of that right that might be
doing you more harm or if you're taking
things you know multiple things they're
counteracting each other in certain ways
yeah and often that is the case as you
introduce more and more supplements and
or medications which are the Same by the
way one's prescribed and one's not both
of them have pharmacodynamic effects
which is what the drug does to the body
in a pharmacokinetic effects which is
how your body metabolizes the drug so if
you're taking that many things then
they're certainly going to be
interaction yeah and look everyone loves
talking about supplements we were all we
were also joking about this beforehand
it's sort of like yeah spirit I get it
like sleep okay but like tell me what
the supplements are that I want to take
because that's the easy lift it's the
easy fix the other lifestyle
modifications require work and habit
formation like you said
um so I'm not against supplementation I
take a bunch of supplements
um but I'm much more cautious I think
than other people who would consider
themselves to be like self-experimenters
and we'll get into it I want to get into
the supplements but you know on the
subject of the foundation of you know
establishing hormonal health and and
just Health generally you know talking
about diet and exercise you know these
things have to come before all of that
they're like the cherry on top right
achieving Optimal Health is kind of like
standing at the top of a quick sand pit
you're never really truly going to get
there but there's many ways that you can
uh you know not be sunk into quicksand
that would be pathology
and the digging out of the quicksander
the walking on top of it that is
learning the lifestyle interventions the
medications and supplements are just
tools and you don't just throw a shovel
at someone and I do recommend mini
shovels those would be your supplements
and medications but you can't throw a
shovel at someone that's sinking and
expect them to get out right so diet
someone comes to you perhaps they're
maybe they're not obese but they got the
love handles they've never been able to
lose them uh metabolically they're a
little bit off
um how are you sort sort of trying to
diagnose that person and you know course
correct their their habits the first
part of taking a history is listening
very closely to a patient
we can call this motivational
interviewing that's kind of a term
that's used in medicine today which uh
rightly puts the emphasis on listening
to the patient many people have when
they by the time they come to you
they've tried many things and some have
worked and some have not and some people
are almost completely better just
because they've found out what works for
them and what doesn't
so listening to them and then also
hearing their goal what they're willing
to do or wanting to do at the time
there's different stages of change and
if they're in the pre-contemplative
phase then perhaps they need just more
motivational interviewing and a better
connection to make a shared decision or
their health needs to decline to the
point where they're actually willing to
make a change that can happen too yeah
um and a lot of it then becomes about
accountability and follow-up right which
is something you're probably better
suited to do than the typical primary
care physician yeah it can be very
difficult to follow up with for example
a specialist some people do follow up
with their specialist and for example a
cardio metabolic clinic at a huge
academic center in a
you know and usually a academic center
in a hospital but
um not everybody can do that there's
just not enough Supply
so following up with a patient
longitudinally and developing that
Rapport or that relationship between the
health care provider and hopefully the
interdisciplinary team I'm a huge fan of
working with many different Healthcare
Providers as a member of a team
dietitians included counselors included
when possible
um
having more Minds to answer the question
is always better sure sure and uh my
sense is that you're someone who's who's
fairly diet agnostic like you're not
adherent to one particular path right
everybody's individual I'm a plant-based
person I've been plant-based for for 15
years
um and you know maybe we differ on some
things but I think we probably agree
that most people who are coming in to
see you who are having some kind of
issue with diet are probably not getting
enough fiber probably not eating enough
Whole Foods probably eating too much
processed foods I mean what do you
typically see and you know more
specifically like what are the things
that you're trying to get people to do
more of and do less of more than 90
percent of people should optimize the
fiber in their diet fiber is not talked
about very much usually you're talking
about the macros of carbs and protein
and fats and sometimes alcohol
but fiber will affect your gut
microbiome pretty significantly and also
your risk of cardiovascular disease
there's many types there is soluble
fiber and insoluble also known as
dietary and non-dietary fiber and then
there's Prebiotic fiber which is heavily
utilized by your gut microbiome so
having enough of all of these and also
not too much there's also types of fiber
called fodmaps which can cause bloating
or gas so having a balance which is
different for every individual is very
important
another thing that we briefly mentioned
about diet is the Mental effects or the
stress effects from diet
if someone has and I think it's
wonderful for everyone to attempt to
grow all of their own food if possible
it is so hard to grow your food so it
really makes you appreciate
any food if you're growing it do you
grow your own food as much as possible
maybe five percent you live in the Bread
Basket come on yeah it's extremely
difficult and we have a huge garden and
we have
15 maybe a 20 chickens now wow so we do
as much as we can and
um the my family's from Kansas and we've
always had Angus Cattle as well and it's
extremely difficult to raise them we
grew up doing 4-H and we raised sheep
and we still uh the family still does
and even with that we just like my
family requires so many more calories
it's amazing that there's so many people
that don't grow their own food and
farmers and other gardeners make up for
it yeah so uh Whole Foods close to their
natural state
um
making sure that you're meeting fiber
demands which most people or a lot of
people are are insufficient at doing
where does that leave you what are your
thoughts on the carnivore diet because
that just seems to be like you know
infecting the internet right now and
people seem to love trying that out and
a lot of people are saying they've had
health benefits from doing that like do
you have a perspective I would put the
carnivore diet in a category of
elimination diets so somewhat in the
same category as for example a Whole 30
where you're trying to you you know you
you want to introduce other foods to see
how you tolerate them I don't think it's
a great Elimination Diet but I
understand why some individuals with
autoimmune diseases want to eliminate
almost everything from their diet and
not have to worry about supplementation
in order to get their like a nutrient
dense
sure diet but you're eating a zero fiber
diet yeah as a result right I would be
particularly concerned for colon cancer
and I would also be concerned for
elevation in the level of iron in the
body it can deposit in any tissues and
oxidize almost like a shovel that's left
outside what about serum cholesterol
it can certainly be concerning for those
on the carnivore diet there is a genetic
component so people can have mutations
and there's one gene called a psck9 gene
where if that's mutated then it's almost
like you're on a um the inhibitor of
that channel right and those people
might be able to tolerate a carnivore
diet and have a particularly low APO B
which is the marker that you really want
to look at but if you compare
individuals that are on plant-based
diets
um if you compared that to the same
individual that was on a carnivore diet
their risk of cardiovascular disease
would be far far lower and the clinical
literature does back this up it's even
been studied looking at plant-based
diets for reversal of plaque in the
coronaries right and APO B being kind of
the favorite
marker for establishing kind of where
you're at where you're at in terms of
cardiovascular disease yeah um there is
a an article published in the Journal of
the American Medical Association the
Cardiology version of it
um the fall of last year I believe it
was Dr Alan snyderman and I think that
journal is going to be the Tipping Point
or the inflection point to where all
lipid panels will reflux so if your LDL
is above say 100 then it's just going to
go ahead and the lab is going to go
ahead and test an APO B after that right
because because now or at least recently
you have to request that it's not part
of the typical panel yeah yeah but
that's changing hopefully it should
change the title of the article if it
means anything was the debate is over
apob is a better marker to check than
LDL yeah yeah
I feel like most people want to eat
better they want to improve their diets
absolutely have you heard of it I've
heard of it this trips up so many people
we thought hey we know a couple things
about how to do this a few so we created
this thing called the plant power meal
planner that is this beautiful offering
whereby you gain access to literally
thousands of plant-based recipes that
you can totally customize based upon
your preferences your allergies your
peccadillos it integrates with grocery
delivery so all the ingredients that you
need get shipped right to your door so
you can make the stuff that you've
pre-selected and we all could use a
little inspiration and support when
preparing meals for our families in our
busy lives so we hope you join us no
matter what your eating style is we have
our arms open wide and we've saved you a
space at our family table to join us in
eating more healthy vibrant plant-based
meals so if you want to learn more if
you want to go on this exploration
that's been so nourishing to Julie and I
I would encourage you to visit meals dot
richroll.com
[Laughter]
you mentioned prebiotics probiotics we
were talking about fiber talk to me a
little bit about the relationship
between uh
the microbiome gut health and Hormone
Health and how those what the interplay
is between those two things I consider
the gut microbiome the front lines of
your immune system so your immune system
is like your military and each any good
military worth their salt will practice
drills and it practices drills against
your gut microbiome as an easy adversary
if your gut microbiome is dysregulated
for example after an antibiotic there
are certain antibiotics that kill more
of your gut microbiome and you see far
more atopy which is allergies asthma and
eczema and also far more inflammatory
diseases like Crohn's and Ultra
ulcerative colitis even after one uh you
know course of antibiotics your odds
ratio which is kind of like think of it
as how many times you're more likely to
get that disease of something like
Crohn's can increase three to four times
wow so if somebody comes in
and you're you're trying to diagnose
them you're going to have to look at gut
Flora
as a marker of Hormone Health and
Hormone Health as a marker of of gut
health yes like these these are not
you know separate entities
some gut microbiota like E coli heavily
produce an enzyme called beta
glucuronidase and your enzyme
metabolizes steroids in part due to
glucuronidase for example estrogen is
metabolized significantly by Beta
glucuronidase
so if you have an overgrowth of E coli
you're going to recirculate your
estrogen and it could relate an estrogen
Surplus got it so on the subject of diet
obviously uh you know what comes to mind
is Weight Management
you practice obesity medicine I'm sure
you see a lot of obese patients or
people that are overweight who come to
you and say I've tried everything I
can't lose the weight and you know
assuming that the laws of thermodynamics
are in place and on some level you know
a calorie in a calorie out is a truth
there are people who no matter what they
do they can't lose the weight we dismiss
them as people who have poor self-will
but in truth there is hormone
dysregulation that creates a different
relationship with appetite and hunger
and also for whatever reason is making
their bodies hold on to weight in in a
manner that's different from somebody
who doesn't suffer from that so there's
a lot of these people out there there
and more and more every day so walk us
through like the experience of of
treating a patient like that and how you
counsel them and and try to better
understand
their Hormone Health and how to improve
it when I'm counseling a patient
regarding improving their Hormone Health
specifically from diet or nutrition
part of the food is medicine philosophy
which is absolutely true
then but let's look at two different
patients one has tried a lot of
different things they've done calorie
counting for a long time
the cat the strict calorie counting or
even going on a very low calorie diet
um
it has not helped and they have either
not lost weight or they've regained
weight and perhaps their metabolism is
lower and their caloric maintenance is
lower as well
versus an individual who hasn't tried
anything and the individual that hasn't
tried anything calorie counting is a
wonderful tool
because in many it does help
that being said even the average doctor
or dietitian
underestimates how many calories they
consume by at least 10 percent so even
doctors and dietitians don't accurately
track yeah accurate caloric intake
but in the individual that has tried
calorie counting and tried very low
calorie diets that individual likely
just needs other tools so sometimes that
is tracking your eating speed sometimes
it's tracking the timing of eating for
example in the morning versus the
evening sometimes it's number of meals
per day sometimes it's carbohydrate or
macronutrient content sometimes it is
the nutrient density versus caloric
density of the food
so all of those things can work but if
someone has already tried strict calorie
counting usually they just need more
help or more tools okay so that's that
person so some people will be able to
Cotton onto that resolve their problem
Go off into the world but let's talk
about the person for whom that doesn't
work and sometimes it can work in
between as well but if that doesn't work
then your tools are those dietary
tracking
mechanisms occasionally
uh you can also give patients a list of
five foods so this is a good actionable
takeaway you list the foods that you
really like for me those might consist
of Greek yogurt unsweetened Greek yogurt
eggs or egg whites spinach I can eat
spinach all day I love it some people do
not like it spinach also has oxalates
which can potentially help bind up heavy
metals in the gut which could be helpful
as well
but you also don't want too many
oxalates if you have kidney stones it's
just another good example of
individualizing a dietary protocol but
those are just some examples of food
that you can eat a lot of and you are un
you're likely to be satiated and
unlikely to be depleted of nutrients
right higher fiber higher in nutrient
density and lower in caloric density
yeah is a good principle but I guess
what I'm getting at is the person who's
whose hormone dysregulated right and you
have to like see what's going on with
that and kind of calibrate the hormones
so that there's a better balance that's
getting struck and the body then becomes
like the the the the metabolic system of
the body becomes more robust and able to
um metabolize food and and perhaps lose
weight like a normal person
yeah and this this would likely require
blood tests which I'm a fan of even if
you don't have any pathology even if you
feel completely normal if you've never
gotten an excellent Baseline panel right
now is a great time to do it
but uh if there is something off then uh
I like to do a full panel including not
just your metabolic hormones as you
think of them for example a fasting
insulin or a glucose tolerance test
which includes multiple glucose levels
or an A1C which is your average blood
sugar over three months but including
your testosterone including your
estradiol many individuals that have a
lower testosterone also slowly lose lean
body mass which is extremely
metabolically active tissue
and also during a caloric deficit many
people
um that you just don't move as much it's
also known as neat or non-exercise
thermogenesis some of that is fidgeting
some of that's just moving back and
forth more often and
um when you have uh problems like these
occasionally it requires supplementation
and or medications to address it and
those medications or supplements would
look like what a good example is if an
individual has metabolic syndrome and
pre-diabetes a high fasting insulin say
over let's say it's 20 which is quite
high for a fasting insulin then perhaps
they're considering medications like
metformin or semi-glutide which are
insulin sensitizers
and uh perhaps their insulin is normal
in that case maybe someone would benefit
more from a medication that would help
balance out that anorexogenic and ores
or exogenic Center of hunger in their
hypothalamus so that would regulate the
hunger impulse to the brain and help
modulate food intake as a result and
perhaps there's a another example of an
individual and their main issue is
eating really late at night or after 8
PM or even eating in between sleep so
they'll wake up and they'll eat and for
that individual perhaps they just
they'll benefit from sleep optimization
when you're sleeping you're not eating
yeah that's my thing eating late at
night
like sometimes it just it's like if I I
know that I'll be able to fall asleep
quickly if I eat something right before
I go to bed but then inevitably I wake
up at like three in the morning yeah and
a lot of that's the orexagenic and the
anorexogenic center so if you're hangry
you're not going to sleep very well yeah
yeah but if I eat too early and I'm
hungry when I go to bed I have trouble
falling asleep yeah it'd be interesting
to see what a uh a CGM would look like
uh I've I've been playing around with
that actually yeah with levels and
that's been super interesting I've
learned quite a bit from that yeah
um
I think the thing with that is you got
to be really careful because I'm a lay
person right I have some signs
vernacular but you know I'm not steeped
in expertise and when you see these
spikes you're like oh my God I have to
stop eating this food like what's normal
what is out of order what should I be
concerned about and what should I not
but the one thing that I did learn is
that in playing around with intermittent
fasting if I
only eat dinner and I eat that dinner a
little bit too late like that's a
disaster it's a disaster for sleep and
when my sleep is dysregulated then my
ability to to metabolize glucose like
Bottoms out and it's terrible the next
day interesting yeah is that typical or
normal it can be typical one thing that
I see pretty often in very healthy
individuals especially that are insulin
sensitive
so they would usually have a lower
fasting insulin it's something called
dawn phenomenon
and that's where often these people are
taking a supplement like berberine which
can precipitously decrease your glucose
especially if you take berberine at
dinner and your glucose will drop very
low and you'll um you can see this on a
CGM as well
most cgms and as it drops low your body
makes glucagon which spikes up your your
glucose even if your insulin is low
so your glucose can be let's say 50 at 3
A.M but by the time you wake up it's
over a hundred right yeah well I'm not
experimenting with that but I I you know
I don't know what's going on metabolic
metabolically with that but
um I learned that like the one meal a
day thing is like no boy no you know I
talked about that with Peter attia he
agreed and I think he had a similar
experience with it I think cgms are a
cool tool I just feel like there needs
to be a lot more education for the
layperson about how to interpret all
this data so that people are are making
informed decisions and not reactive
decisions to momentary spikes and data
inputs that they don't truly understand
yes I certainly agree um again that's
another example many individuals see
that they have a spike of glucose so
they start taking a powerful insulin
sensitizer like berberine and it can
make the problem worse rather than
butter right right right
um how about the person who kind of
rubber bands like this the guy who or
the woman who
um you know loses a tremendous amount of
weight and then six months later has
gained all the weight back what is that
doing to somebody metabolically and and
hormonally like my sense is that over
time that's damaging the metabolic
health of the individual and probably
making it harder for them to keep that
weight off in a healthy way long term
much of it has to do with losing the
lean body mass perhaps not to a point of
sarcopenia which is a pathologically low
lean body mass but perhaps to the point
where
their metabolism or their lean body mass
is so low that their daily caloric
intake they're used to they're
accustomed to consuming this many
calories and now they can't even consume
that many so that that's the main
mechanism behind what is kind of
culturally known as metabolic damage and
it certainly happens
more than 90 percent of individuals who
lose weight tend to gain it back the
thing that the small percentage of
individuals that keep the weight off
have in common is an exercise habit so
it doesn't help lose weight but it can
help prevent the lean body mass from
decreasing and the body fat from coming
back all right well that's a good segue
into exercise but before we put diet in
the rear view mirror we probably should
talk a little bit about the differences
between the Sexes right so we've just
sort of talked about this generally at
least with respect to Weight Management
like how does it differ hormonally
between men and women women do have
menstrual cycles of course if they're
before menopause and after menarchy and
during some areas depending on your
genetics you may have different dietary
needs for example if there's a a female
that has PCOS men do not have PCOS we
don't have ovaries then they might
require a diet that is not as a lower
glycemic diet or a diet to address the
Androgen dominance so something to help
increase their shbg which could consist
of a low carb diet
whereas a male would not be concerned
with that pathology on the other end
there's also women with one another
example of a pathology is hypothalamic
amenorrhea which has to do with many
different inputs but one of them is
leptin leptin is a a hormone that is a
signaling molecule from fat cells that
can help increase the production of the
hormones in the hypothalamus that then
release FSH and LH from the pituitary so
those in each individualized dietary
needs for females would be drastically
different than right and so what would
be common interventions or prescriptions
with respect to food in that regard
specifically for PCOS often they benefit
from less carbs you're trying to get
shbg which is The Binding protein that
binds up androgens and estrogens you're
trying to get that higher often you see
a deficient level of shbg or sex hormone
binding globulin in individuals with
PCOS or just individuals with insulin
resistance insulin acts on the liver to
decrease shbg production from the liver
and then their their hormones are
metabolized very quickly and they also
just run around unregulated right so
that's women right so and what about on
the guy's side for the guy's side uh
guys do have shpg and of course men and
women have very similar hormones
women have different ratios of hormones
usually women have about four times as
much testosterone than estrogen and men
have many times that more testosterone
than estrogen but estrogen is
particularly important
you can see low shbgs and men as well
you usually want a medium or a high shpg
A good rule of thumb in Min is that you
want estrogen to be as high as they can
tolerate without many symptoms but you
want a total estradiol about two to
three times a free testosterone
and you also want shbg on the high end
as well as long as you can maintain
adequate free androgens right so when
you say estrogen and Men people lose
their minds yeah yeah it's it is
certainly good unless it is
High relative test to testosterone so
often you want to keep the estrogen nice
and high but just increase the
testosterone congruently and are there
typical foods that can help balance that
or buttress uh you know things in the
right direction for that individual
ensuring that you're getting optimal uh
essential fatty acids and essential
amino acids for example Omega-3s or your
essential amino acids that's first and
foremost for some for many people that
might be more than the RDA
of that nutrient
and then depending on
um you know what other pathology that
individual might have that would come
next but many people are you know the
most common problem is
too many calories especially processed
calories
I think that the effects of
phytoestrogens are quite weak in most
individuals including males and I think
the effects of xenoestrogen so
phytoestrogens are things that can
potentially be estrogenic for example
soy most individuals do not consume
enough to have a clinically significant
effect perhaps that's statistically
significant if you design a study to see
that
um xenoestrogens likely do have a touch
of an effect an example of that would be
bisphenol a and that would bind to an
estrogen related receptor the gamma
receptor so that could have hormonal
effects but again likely these are not
significant compared to everything else
that is happening but it's certainly
something to keep in mind and what foods
are Xeno uh uh what did you say you said
Xeno
xenoestrogens estrogen estrogens in the
environment like BPA okay which is known
as bisphenol a so you might see your
water bottle sure BPA free which is
great and then phytoestrogens are
somewhat estrogenic from Plants right
but usually they are very weak right
okay and if anything they're beneficial
right okay let's talk about exercise uh
talk to me generally about how you think
of think about exercise as this second
pillar exercise uh and again another
analogy it is how
you keep your body using so it would be
like you have a new brand new car and
then you put it in a garage
and you put it up on a lift it's like
being in a chair and you never use it
you never drive it that car is not going
to function well even if you leave it
there for a year you're going to have to
change the oil and whatnot because it
hasn't been moving
um but humans are the same way you can't
just put a human and sit them down in a
artificial indoor environment they're
designed to move you have anaerobic and
aerobic exercise and both are
particularly important whether it's the
um you know the easier exercise I know
Peter attia talks a lot about Zone 2
cardio which is particularly important
but vigorous exercise is also important
of course as is resistance training so
zone two how much
when how does that differ with age would
be my first question and how does that
mix in like in the in the if you're
looking at somebody who's pretty busy
and you're saying you got to do zone two
you got to do resistance training you
got to do some like interval high output
stuff like what is the ratio of those
activities to your mind the law of
diminishing returns applies in this case
as it does in almost everything in
medicine
um so it's hard to say you know this is
the amount of zone two that it's
beneficial for you and after that it
completely drops off a good rule of
thumb is three times a week 30 minutes
for zone two and at least one time a
week of very vigorous cardio and at
least twice a week for resistance
training so that would be pretty
reasonable for a busy person to do right
how about 25 hours of zone two a week
uh I've been there that way that would
be a lot
um
the aerobic base is huge well the great
thing about zone two is it's a day in
day out thing like I my my the way I
think about it is that's the kind of
thing where you can kind of wait if
you're doing it properly you can kind of
wake up every day and do it you're not
going to be overly fatigued but your
high output stuff you got to pace it out
because you do I have to allow your body
to recover so it's about like you know
being mindful of spacing the workouts so
that you're giving your body time to
heal and get stronger absolutely
true over training is relatively rare
although perhaps an individual like
yourself yeah would not it would always
be on in your world you're probably
always teetering on the edge but for the
average American most are not over
trained they're just getting used to
that adaptation and
um for an individual like that the let's
just say the average American
starting and emphasizing vigorous
exercise can be detrimental because that
they feel so tired or sore at least the
the first month to where they're not
wanting to incorporate things like zone
two and and walk me through what's going
on hormonally when you exercise and I'm
sure it's different depending upon the
type of exercise but bring the hormones
into the discussion
the so hormones during exercise have
been very well studied there's a ton of
clinical literature published on it and
there are
effects on not only testosterone and
estrogen but also growth hormone and
igf-1
a lot of this is released in and amongst
muscle cells so not necessarily
endocrine which is between body systems
but autochronoperacrine
and usually these effects are very short
so if you do it just a couple times it's
not going to have a sustained effect
but over a long period of time it is
likely clinically significant
so ways to optimize a lot of people ask
about how to optimize your growth
hormone you have peripheral and Central
growth hormone you don't necessarily
want to optimize both and you also have
testosterone that can be increased one
of the studies that many people have
talked about is if you do a set of
resistance training with legs I believe
squats is usually the example
and you do a medium rep range for a
medium number of sets three to four sets
six to ten reps then it can help
optimize your Androgen profile
specifically testosterone
if you do this just one time and the
testosterone is not going to be around
systemically for a long period of time
if you look at the graph it decreases
pretty quickly so if it becomes a habit
then it can help in the long run but if
you're just if you're only doing it once
a month or once every other month it's
very unlikely to have a clinically
significant effect right on the subject
of over training the the kind of
Catchphrase that comes up often is
adrenal fatigue my sense is that adrenal
fatigue is not a thing it's it's
something that we attach to a sense of
not having energy or general lethargy
but if somebody says I have adrenal
fatigue Kyle like help me out what's
going on like how do you figure out what
the problem is and identify is this an
over training thing is this a stress
thing like what is happening adrenal
fatigue is still not an ICD-10 code what
does that mean there's different codes
that you can put in and order tests and
diagnostic under ah and adrenal fatigue
is still not one of those you can have
Addison's disease which is a lack of
adrenal hormones that are made in this
specifically
cortisol and I believe DHEA are made in
the Zona reticulosa which is a part of
the adrenal gland a small gland on top
of the kidney
DHEA in particular is very interesting
one because it produces all of the
estrogen and post-menopausal women
and then two because DHEA is like the
pawn on the chestboard of hormones
so if you're looking at your hormones
like a chess board specifically your
androgens and your estrogens
let's say your Queens are estrogen you
don't have very much estrogen but
they're really important and it can be
extremely beneficial for your health
you also have your say Rooks or
androgens
but your pawns are DHEA and through life
as your Hormone Health progresses your
pawns can be Queen so DHEA can convert
to both testosterone and estrogen which
it does quite often so if you have
worsening function of the ovary or
testes the adrenals can back up your
hormone function
and DHEA is something that you get
through omega-3s
is that correct DH about right DHA is it
omega-3 okay I get confused between all
the DHS yeah
um however DHEA is an over-the-counter
supplement so in some countries I
believe the UK and Canada it is in
medication there is a
um a scientist uh recently passed away I
believe his name was Dr Fernand lobry
and he's interesting because he was the
one that showed that prostate cancer
treatments that basically shut down the
pituitary from producing
um the hormones that cause Androgen
release if you treat that then prostate
cancer is not as bad and it actually
extends life so that was like the first
prostate cancer drug that extended life
however he also studied DHEA for quality
of life so it's interesting the same
scientist studied both a cancer
treatment to decrease hormones and also
study DHEA
however it the the data on DHEA is kind
of unclear because there can be a widely
different and a full order of magnitude
or 10 times between individuals some
produce a ton
and that can be called adrenal
hyperplasia a lot of people have a gene
for this called nccah
and then there's also a phenomenon
that's known as adrenopause which is
similar to menopause or andropause but
where your adrenals shut down and this
happens for everyone but just at very
different times of life right and if
somebody is truly over trained what is
what is going on with them hormonally
and how do you help them get out of that
hole
often they have a decrease of cortisol
and also DHEA and downstream to that
testosterone and estrogen that are
peripherally converted
so their adrenal glands are not working
as well if you look at the enzymes in
the steroidogenesis Cascade it's very
interesting a lot of the same enzymes
that tonkat Ali works on also known as
long Jack but a lot of the enzymes that
that works on insulin and igf-1 work on
so things like fasting or things like a
lot of cardiovascular exercise can down
regulate those enzymes
also the stimulating hormone that comes
from your pituitary to stimulate
cortisol production also stimulates DHEA
to some degree so if you're very insulin
sensitive or if you're eating one meal a
day then that is going to detrimentally
impact the production of adrenal
hormones and also down regulate the
stronagenesis Cascade in each tissue
right
um got that like huberman got me on the
tongaat Alley a while back like he's a
big he's all about that but that would
be one prescription to address that
dysregulation often you hear with
athletes who who truly are over trained
like Elite athletes who just dig this
hole like it takes them sometimes it
takes them six months
to truly come out of that phase and I'm
I can't help but wondering like if they
go to see you perhaps there's a way to
if somebody you know oversteps and is in
that situation is there a way to
shortcut not shortcut but just compress
that time period of getting somebody
back to Baseline there's a lag in the
upregulation of those enzymes urinary
metabolite hormone test or even salivary
tests can help tell us more because it
tells you how your body's metabolizing
hormones both androgens estrogens and
progestogens and if there's a specific
enzymatic step which looks like the rate
limiting step then we can address that
through supplementation or dietary
changes
you know if you're looking at two
individuals and let's just talk about
Tong cat for example's sake
there's one individual that has PCOS
they likely will not benefit as much
from Tomcat because they've already up
regulated many of the same enzymes with
their excess insulin or with their
adequate insulin or igf-1 signaling
whereas another individual who is an
endurance athlete and who has been in a
caloric deficit perhaps and is very
insulin sensitive could benefit greatly
from Tomcat yeah interesting
prophets Walk Among Us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years I've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share those
that we don't know who can teach us
something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing and so I've dedicated my career
to tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why I'm proud to announce the release of
my new book voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration and Timeless wisdom that
transpires each week on the ritual
podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table and volume 2
follows in that tradition by showcasing
even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication replete with
interview excerpts essays and stunning
photography making for an Exquisite
companion to the first volume or a
satisfying Standalone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday prophets and physically
interact with the life-changing ideas
contained with this
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
I can't help but ask about like my own
personal you know I'm going to make this
about me having a session with you but
you know as an aging endurance athlete
like I'm 55 now and I feel good and you
know I I go in and out of how fit I am
and I'm certainly not doing 25 hours of
zone two now but I you know I do get out
and get after it and I have my good days
and my bad days and you know as I get
older
you know obviously the more fit I am the
less likely this is but like in my
current state I'll have really good days
and but I I do need to be much more
careful and cautious about my recovery
days and perhaps we can get into
supplementation later but in terms of
how I'm approaching my day in kind of
day outfit day out fitness as somebody
who you know is the age that I'm at and
also as a plant-based athlete you know
without doing a whole blood panel on me
like what would be top level kind of
general counsel or advice to help me
kind of level up for an endurance
athlete in your age group who is
presumably Desiring a fairly Optimal
Performance a longevity of Optimal
Performance in addition to continuing
the activities that you like there is
definitely a lot of Truth to use it or
lose it
looking at supplementation or dietary
sources of things like creatine or
L-Carnitine would be particularly
interesting when you're thinking about a
male individual I also think about the
activity of the Androgen receptor
without getting too technical basically
the activity or the gene transcription
of this receptor is what matters it's
not the actual level of testosterone or
dihydrotestosterone they all bind the
same receptor so the sensitivity of that
receptor matters and the density of that
receptor matters
I've played around with creatine it's
certainly effective uh but I I
definitely retain a ton of water weight
when I do that so I kind of cycle on and
off it it's pretty safe though like you
don't necessarily have to cycle with
that is my understanding
um but I don't like to be on it for
extended period of times because I I
literally feel like I'm carrying around
like 15 extra pounds yeah creatine has a
couple of hormonal effects it can a
somewhat upregulate five Alpha reductase
so it can convert a touch more
testosterone to DHT which could be good
if someone tends to be estrogen dominant
but it could also be bad
um also creatine I think of as a backup
fuel tank so you can retain water some
of it is in the sarcoplasm hopefully
most of it which is in the muscle cell
so perhaps that works but creatine is
kind of like the backup fuel tank
um NAD which can be converted from nmn
and NR that's kind of like the fuel
itself coenzyme Q10 helps convert that
NAD into ATP which is the fuel in the
mitochondria it's actually think of it
as your Powerhouse there's also some
evidence that uh there may be some
cognitive enhancement and mood
enhancement with creatine it seems like
the science on that is more recent
creatinine to some degree beta in are
also involved in amino acid synthesis
and a lot of those amino acids shunt
into the different Cycles to help with
energy generation within the cell which
happens in the brain too of course
also they can help with
depleting your body of intermediaries
like homocysteine some people are
predisposed for their homocysteine to
build up so things like creatine and
beta in can potentially help decrease
that interesting and walk me through
L-Carnitine I've never I've never taken
that I know it's not very bioavailable
but I don't know much beyond that
correct about what it does and it's the
smallest peptide hormone it's just two
amino acids put together
um so you can take L-Carnitine in a
supplement it's very hard it's kind of
like creatine it's hard for your body to
synthesize a lot of L-Carnitine
so if you take it it's probably only
about 10 bioavailable it can also
potentially increase tmao like choline
which is a potential carcinogen in the
gut that's not so good yeah so you do
need to be a bit careful if you have a
healthy gut microbiome it's unlikely
your tmao will increase
conversely if your tmao is increased
it's likely that your gut microbiome is
not healthy but back to L-Carnitine it
has a couple different functions but
just think of it as the fuel pump it
makes your pumping the
um
the energy into your mitochondria very
efficient specifically types of fatty
acids that are average in length I think
they're called medium chain fatty acids
and they can also help your cells and
mitochondria uptake glucose
the main thing that I'm getting from all
of this is just how complicated it is
right like
it's pretty ill-advised for the consumer
to just say well I'm going to you know
take a spin on the L-Carnitine thing
without understanding tmao and whether
you have a high level or whether you're
more receptive to that getting increased
as a results like these are not
decisions that should be made casually
right decisions like this should be made
with the help of your interdisciplinary
team for example a dietitian or a
medical doctor right but most people
don't have an interdisciplinary team let
alone a Kyle Gillette on speed dial
right like you're running a very unique
special clinic and service that is you
know probably not accessible for the
vast majority of people and although
there are more and more practitioners
like yourself as we mentioned at the
outset popping up and available it's
still not you know a highly accessible
thing so for the person who's listening
to this who's just trying to get their
head around this and maybe what they
should or shouldn't do like
I'm wondering like is this more
confusing than helpful like if they
don't have somebody that they can call
upon who can actually give them you know
real guided counsel yeah um any guidance
is better than none and I am certainly
an advocate of personal freedom so
people are free to do with their bodies
whatever they may want to I think that's
a reasonable stance to take for many
medications and supplements the dose
makes the poison so I guess the action
item for that would be if you're
considering L-Carnitine and you just
want to take it even if you're not
getting blood tests then perhaps take
you know 750 or a thousand milligrams
perhaps don't inject a thousand
milligrams which does not worry about
bioavailability without the supervision
of a physician and perhaps don't take
five grams daily without the supervision
right and and don't conflate it by
taking other things right so you can
kind of monitor the variables
yeah
um as somebody who's been plant-based
for 15 years and there's a lot of
plant-based people that tune into this
show like what would be top of mind for
you in terms of what I should be
thinking about or perhaps supplementing
or if you were to do my blood panel like
what would you be looking for in terms
of you know things that might commonly
occur in somebody who's been eating only
plants for a long time certainly the
well-known ones like vitamin B12 or
ferritin or vitamin D when you're
looking at vitamin B12 especially if
you're on acid blockers and such
it can be bioavailable it can also be
not very bioavailable
and then on top of that there's many
forms of B12 so you have things like
methylcobalamin which is also a methyl
donor and then you have cyanocobalamin
or adenocobalamin so there's many
different forms yeah and there's always
this debate as to which one you should
be taking my B12 is fine by the way but
yeah like there's plenty of B12
supplements available it's very
affordable it's easy to do but it's like
should I do the cobalamin or the
methylcobalamin like which one
cyanocobalamin if you check uh but one
if you want to get really into it you
can check your MTHFR polymorphism there
is such a thing as too much methylation
even if you have one variant of MTHFR
but without getting too technical if you
check a homocysteine and a B12 and
perhaps MMA which is a methylmalonic
acid then that should tell you if you
need a specific type of B12 most people
do not need methylcobalamin so by
default start with cyanocobalamin that's
safe way to start monitor your levels
and if they're fine you don't have to
worry about it
yeah I would say a reasonable like bare
minimum biomarker to check for an
individual on a plant-based diet is a
B12 and a homocysteine
yeah mine are good there ferritin's a
little tiny bit low but like not
alarming so I've sort of been upping my
iron content in the plant Foods a couple
points on ferritin is ferritin is a
pretty good indicator of the iron level
throughout your body however it is also
an acute phase reactant so it can be
artificially elevated if it you're
during a period of inflammation for
example illness or autoimmune disease
so if you got your blood work done
during that period of time you would be
misinformed correct someone could have a
ferritin of 200 and they could think uh
they actually might think that's too
high right in some cases but uh they
could still be iron deficient right got
it
um let's talk about stress and stress
optimization so how are you thinking
about this in the context of Hormone
Health
yeah
um a lot of people have uh you know in
this this kind of encompasses mental
health as well and social health maybe
we do need to add a seventh one there
but
um you want to have something that
requires great effort life is
extraordinarily difficult
and you want to be able to have a
positive mindset or a glass half full or
even glass quarter full
outlook on your stress there's a lot of
tools like mindfulness or meditation or
even prayer
which kind of delves into the spiritual
pillar as well
but you want to be
[Music]
um
you want to have just enough effort in
the areas that bring you purpose but you
also want to control your stress
fortunately we are concentrated on the
self-actualization part of Maslow's
hierarchy of needs so we're not as
concerned with our physical or bare
essential needs
but um the level of stress is still
there so humans have had a very
stressful existence
when the stress is not proportionate to
the threat it can be unnecessary and it
can affect your Hormone Health and it
can affect the health of the rest of
your household as well acute stress in
certain controllable scenarios good
chronic stress bad but as you know we
live in an epidemic of of chronic
low level the high grade stress and
we've kind of acclimated to that as a as
a normal right everybody's stressed out
everybody's anxious and our lifestyles
you know are kind of oriented around
being in environments that that
produce it uh you know support that and
you know
you could tell people you need to
meditate you need to have a mindfulness
practice but you know the boss is
yelling and the kids are crying and
they're upload you know all of these
sorts of things that are just part and
parcel of like getting through life
which is difficult have created in the
western industrialized world this
epidemic that's driving Downstream all
of these you know metabolic health
problems from obesity to diabetes Etc so
talk about the like get into the
hormones of chronic stress and what
that's doing to us and how it's just
regulating our health and how that um
impacts us you know down the line in all
these other ways we can think about the
adrenal axis of stress and we can also
think about the neurotransmitter axis of
stress
so one of the ways that your body will
acclimate to stress including physical
stress is increasing cortisol which is a
glucocorticoid which can decrease muscle
mass and cause an increase in blood
glucose if you give someone a medication
like prednisone which is basically a
medication version of cortisol then and
if you give them to them for a long time
then they will develop diabetes and also
excess body fat and decreased muscle
mass
wow so basically like like sort of
extrapolating on that idea essentially
what you're saying is if you're in a
chronic state of of stress it doesn't
matter how great your diet is or how
well you're sleeping this you know
cortisol issue could create type 2
diabetes in you nonetheless correct
um a pathologic overproduction of it is
known as Cushing's disease
so that can also be
very detrimental for your health it
needs to follow very closely
but there's a Continuum or Spectrum in
between
where you can have cortisol
overproduction there's even supplements
that can potentially help control
cortisol ashwagandha is likely one of
them and emodin is another one I think
it's derived from rhubarb
so again with cortisol the dose can make
the poison as well
the other act the other main axis of
stress that would be hormonal would be
your adrenergic
um
nervous system
you also have things like dopamine
epinephrine and norepinephrine
catecholamines basically the think of
this as if you're acutely stressed your
fight or flight nervous system is
activated classically this would be you
know you would either fight a lion or
run from it
so you have an increase in those
hormones epinephrine is also known as
adrenaline if they're elevated for a
long period of time again it can lead to
body fat accumulation excess hunger and
it can also lead to desensitization of
those receptors dopamine receptors and
also adrenaline receptors can be
desensitized very quickly that's why
many individuals that are on medications
that stimulate or simulate your dopamine
and your adrenaline or noradrenaline
require higher and higher doses Adderall
would be the main example of one of
those medications sure and obviously
that's applicable to the addiction
scenario as well substance addiction or
behavior addiction right because
hormonally your does your body even know
the difference
and there's many scientists for example
Andrew huberman that talk in detail
about the dopaminergic system and how it
affects your motivation
and how it is closely related to
testosterone so your androgens and your
dopamine are very closely related
I describe your dopamine as a pool
specifically a wave pool where you do
expect natural fluctuations up and down
but depending on if you have an overflow
of dopamine your body can make that wave
pool deeper to try to accommodate for
that and then you're only filling up
half the pool and even if you have a
normal amount of dopamine you can feel
depleted interesting so for somebody who
has enough self-awareness to know that
they go in and out of some level of
chronic anxiety or stress uh what is the
what does the science look like in terms
of
from a hormonal perspective like if you
adopt a consistent meditation practice
like have they studied okay here's how
this is impacting hormone regulation in
the body as a result of like a formal
practice or some version of that that is
a de-stressor
from the cortisol or sympathetic
overdrive
that has been studied and a a meditation
or a relaxation practice or even just
walking and being around green plants
and trees can be helpful
or even being around more sunlight
but from a an androgen standpoint I'm
not sure if it would optimize your
testosterone or estrogen
but clearly effective it's one of your
pillars yes right you stand by it yes
for sure um well it gets into it kind of
gets into your next pillar the sunlight
pillar which you know is kind of about
being in nature right and and there's
also a microbiome piece to that as well
sort of breathe your biome like being
immersed in you know a multitude of of
you know species of plant and animal
life and breathing that in and grounding
your feet in the soil and all and you
know doing the sun gazing as Andrew
talks about and all of that like like
you know our our kind of Western minds
are very dismissive of that but this is
the missing link we've become so
detached from you know that that you
know very healing and Primal fundamental
aspect of what it means to be human
humans have uh
are definitely adapted to be outdoors
even if it feels easier to be indoors
there are so many uh regulatory checks
and balances that come with being
outside and being in nature
that it is very difficult to have
Optimal Health if you are not doing that
so people have studied you know
cognitive function if you have a Vista
so if you have a view and you can see a
mile then it is significantly better
than if you can then if there's another
house right next door what about when
you're walking through the forest though
the deep forest yeah uh I would say
being around the new clean fresh air in
the forest is helpful being around the
green is also helpful
um being aware of your environment even
if there are no dangerous animals in the
area then you're still just more
peripherally aware
um you can discuss the like the benefits
of using your peripheral vision
um not looking directly at something and
your mind will shift Focus
and there's many different benefits from
that you also happen to be moving at the
same time perhaps you get some cold
exposure or heat exposure at the same
time it's a very high yield intervention
right so what is the prescription like
what what goes on your notepad to the to
the patient when it comes to the
sunlight pillar
often trying to get good morning
sunlight being outside throughout the
day often you can combine this with
exercise for example if you work a desk
job and are indoors all day then take a
walk after lunch maybe even with your
co-workers and colleagues to hit the
social piece as well
if someone does work Outdoors then
perhaps it's not they've already dialed
in that pillar and they don't need to do
anything at all
but making that some kind of daily
practice or habit and that can fold into
the exercise piece as well obviously
right often you can do two or three or
four at the same time yeah yeah yeah
yeah well while you mentioned cold and
heat exposure so maybe this is a good
time to kind of explore
some of those therapies it's all the
rage right now much like you know
intermittent fasting and all of that
everybody wants to talk about their ice
baths and their saunas and how do you
think about these protocols and their
impact specifically on Hormone Health
they're good protocols for the
individual attempting to optimize things
like any other intervention you need to
be careful of the common missteps
so I would say if you're and the sauna
is not as much this way but jacuzzi in
hot tub or even heated seats could
definitely be this way if you're trying
to optimize your fertility then be
careful for heat damage to the testes
and testes like to be several degrees
cooler than the rest of the body so if
you're in especially warm very warm
water for a long period of time
then that can decrease sperm counts
right as far as the benefits of cold
exposures like cold dunks you're
avoiding frostbite and you don't want to
get hypothermia as well so usually it is
a very quick intervention a cold shower
can be it's not quite as good as a cold
dunk but it can be a good start so for
the individual trying to get the most
bang for their Buck a cold shower and
then if you have access to a sauna Asana
from time to time is a great place to
start do you have a sense of what's more
efficacious from a Hormone Health
perspective uh cryotherapy versus Ice
baths
there seems to be a raging debate about
the pros and cons of these two things
from a hormonal standpoint for let's say
there's an individual with a varicocele
which is basically varicose veins in the
gonadal area then they are often already
too warm and
um
cooling can be particularly beneficial
and the more dose of cooling the more
helpful it is so for that individual
where their testes are likely too warm
due to varicose veins it is extremely
helpful the more cold exposure you have
but I think that you were asking about
like cryotherapy versus Ice baths yeah
yeah ice baths perhaps slightly more
helpful from a from like a hormonal but
perhaps just from a spermatogenesis
standpoint
there's been a lot of debates on whether
or not ice baths are helpful for
Recovery specifically of endurance
athletes I used to run track as well and
always had to take an ice bath and I
don't believe the evidence on that came
out to be as helpful right I mean the
the debate has something to do with the
the greater conduciveness of temperature
in water versus Air so you're in cryo
for a shorter period of time but it's
also much colder than the ice bath but
the water in the ice bath is gonna
conduct that heat transfer more
effectively I would think that the ice
bath is more helpful for those that have
um
like more heat damage to begin with so
probably probably a nice bath right well
as a as a former track and field athlete
who has experience with the recovery
benefits of you know being in a nice
bath
I often wonder I'm interested in your
perspective on this I often wonder about
many of these recovery enhancement tools
whether it's normatec boots or ice baths
or sauna or turmeric or some of the
foods that are you know hyper
antioxidants we're all trying to
expedite that recovery window so that we
can wake up the next day and go harder
than we would have been able to
otherwise so that we can achieve gains
in a more compressed period of time
but I often wonder whether
taking advantage of all of these
recovery tools is robbing the body's
adaptive process like we want the body
to figure out how to adapt and recover
on its own right and when we kind of do
it for the body are we not
um sort of undercutting the benefits
that we're trying to seek by exercise
induced stress that's definitely true
there is I believe a a clinician from
Harvard years and years ago that turned
that coined the term rice rest ice
compression elevation
and the it looks like the ice part of
rice is not particularly helpful and
even the compression part of rice is
also less likely to be helpful for
Recovery purposes because of a lot of
the natural healing mechanisms where you
have that warm swelling infiltrate of
growth factors and uh of vegf which can
help with vasculogenesis and healing I'm
blocking those things can be detrimental
so it is far more rare that we recommend
things like NSAIDs unless someone needs
them for pain what's an inside even then
they're usually better options ibuprofen
or Aleve so ibuprofen or naproxen would
be the generic so in general I do not
recommend those for injuries and I also
do not necessarily recommend rice right
so better to be old school like I think
there's certain uh situations in which
it's appropriate if you're if you've
really pushed it hard you know and you
know you still have a big week ahead or
you're you know leading up to a race or
something like that but on a day-to-day
basis like yeah you you kind of want you
you want that inflammatory response on
some level like this is where your body
is doing what it's supposed to be doing
absolutely it's somewhat like an
endogenous form of PRP PRP is just
platelet-rich plasma and that swelling
and heat is bringing your body's plasma
without having to take it out of your
system centrifuge it and put it back in
and so when you do the Heat and the cold
and the boots and all the stuff you're
telling your body don't worry about it
you don't have to do that like we got
this yeah so I would say you certainly
don't want to do that every single day
but from time to time it's reasonable
right like what would be the appropriate
use case then to your mind leading up to
an event where you want to
perform well you're not recovering from
injury or like a difficult phase many
people have like mesocycles or different
phases of their workouts
um so during a phase where you're really
breaking things down
um perhaps trying to avoid it and then
in your last phase leading up to the
event even if it's not as difficult to
perhaps using then right
um sleep
talk about sleep uh obviously
good sleep hygiene is going to improve
your Hormone Health and good Hormone
Health is going to improve your sleep
right so how does this complex interplay
work this one's pretty direct you
produce most of your testosterone and
growth hormone when you sleep
testosterone has a pretty big spike in
the morning cortisol actually does as
well and in the evening your melatonin
spikes these different spikes can be
offset so they can happen at the wrong
time
growth hormone is released it's a very
short half-life of just minutes and it's
pulsatile so you'll get a pulse and get
a pulse and then that'll secondarily
help increase igf-1
so if your sleep is disrupted it's very
common to have decreased levels of
testosterone or decreased growth hormone
in fact obstructive sleep apnea or sleep
apnea in general is one of the main
pathologies that you see as a cause of
hypoconadism right so I want to get into
testosterone in a few minutes but if
you're thinking well my testosterone is
low low but my sleep is dysregulated
before going on you know testosterone
replacement therapy maybe dial in the
sleep yes I have seen it be extremely
efficacious it's a much better
testosterone booster than any supplement
if you happen to have a sleep disorder
and you do want good quality and
quantity so a general rule of thumb is
seven to eight hours each night
try to go to bed at the same time for
some people like shift workers this can
be particularly difficult and then
you're looking to have good deep sleep
and good REM sleep as well yeah and and
there's a relationship between REM sleep
and fertility right so talk about that a
little bit REM sleep along with zone two
cardiovascular exercise are kind of the
two best interventions to help with
mitochondrial health and the
mitochondria
um just like anything else in the body
they will produce energy to help you do
things like meiosis or to do things like
forming the spindle which is basically
you're pulling all your genome apart and
then putting it back together but just
in in two halves so for both
males and females they help the
mitochondria in the germ cell line which
is like the gamete line
function so that REM sleep will help
your body correctly put all the genetic
material where it is supposed to go
so on a typical night like I've got I'd
wear a whoop I pay attention to my sleep
metrics if I sleep eight hours sometimes
my REM sleep is two and a half hours
sometimes it's one and a half hours
there tends to be a pretty consistent
ratio between deep and REM like I'm
always striving to get like I feel best
when I've had
a minimum of two hours of deep and two
and a half hours of REM like that I
don't always hit that right but when I
hit that like I'm I'm like good to go
right so
is that ratio like on par what's
interesting is like I can sleep eight
hours but sometimes you know those
numbers between deep and REM are all
over the place so eight just saying you
got to sleep eight hours isn't really
the best metric or indicator for Sleep
hygiene
correct you can sleep a very long period
of time but the quality of the sleep
will not be very good before stressful
events your sleep tends to be shorter
duration but actually higher quality
and part of that could be the
cholinergic nervous system
acetylcholine is the neurotransmitter
that can help with different receptors
in that system like nicotinic receptors
that nicotine also binds to and
muscarinic receptors
so you want to ensure that you have
optimal acetylcholine throughout the
body some things that uptake
acetylcholine like cuparazine is a
supplement that some people take to
theoretically improve their REM sleep
especially if they don't have enough
acetylcholine can potentially help with
that what is that called again
hooperazine a it's a very weak
acetylcholinesterase inhibitor so it
basically can help increase
acetylcholine there's also different
cholinergic precursors like
phosphatidylserine or
phosphatidylcholine or Alpha GPC that
are precursors to acetylcholine
and then some people that are trying to
optimize REM sleep will take things that
are nicotinic receptor Agonist
like uh taybacks or cystinium which is a
different plant not a tobacco plant that
forms the alkaloid nicotine but a
different plant that forms the alkaloid
cystanine and those are over-the-counter
supplements that you have a pension for
prescribing to people who are
dysregulated in their sleep at times REM
sleep can be particularly difficult
because it's one of the hardest to track
a baseline heart rate and heart rate
variability tend to be extremely
accurate on wearables but REM sleep is
kind of more like the gut microbiome or
even cholesterol where you're really
looking at the trend within the
individual rather than the actual level
yeah but your senses HRV is pretty
accurate with things like this and the
aura and stuff like that
um
how do we think about HRV like I'm
always comparing mine to my friends and
you know I know it's a highly
individualized thing yeah and I guess
intellectually I kind of know what it is
and what it means but I don't think I
really know what it means or why it's
important it can tell us a ton
um there's a scientist uh also at
Stanford Dr Michael Snyder I believe and
he talks about his experience with heart
rate variability and predicting periods
of stress or even predicting illnesses
and within the individual if you're very
accustomed to knowing what your heart
rate variability is and what makes it
Trend up or down then it can tell you a
ton but if you're going to put on a
wearable and then wear it for one day
and look at your artery variability it's
going to tell you almost nothing right
so to Define it though HRV means I don't
know that I can say this eloquently but
it's the variability in the amount of
time between heartbeats right and
correct you don't want that that
intermittent in between B to be the same
amount of time every time when it varies
quite a bit the greater the variability
there the greater indicator of Health
yes why is that you have uh two
different parts of your autonomic
nervous system your heart you're not
um you know consciously telling your
heart to beat so it's maintained by a
balance between your sympathetic nervous
system
an example of that would be adrenaline
makes your heart beat faster and your
parasympathetic nervous system the main
nerve that that controls is called the
vagus nerve which is actually a cranial
nerve and it runs down innervates some
of your gut too by the way and then it
goes back into your heart and you have
the sinoatrial node and the atrial
ventricular node
so depending on how much activity your
nervous system has on those two nodes
that will determine what your heart rate
is one good way to see how your body can
adapt to this is taking a deep breath
that's also known as a physiologic PSI
to where you can take one example is two
deep breaths or three deep breaths
through your nose and then a deep breath
out through your mouth
as you do that you can have well one
thing is called physiologic splitting of
the heart sound you can actually hear
the ventricles in the Atria contract
that's slightly different levels because
as your lungs expand it basically pushes
on the heart the pressure between the
heart and the lungs will change so your
heart rate will change as you take that
deep breath or sigh interesting wow and
so how did this become why is that
related to health like it's just
flexibility like metabolic flexibility
or what you know why is it in such an
important indicator
if your heart does not adapt well to the
pressure that is put on it
then it could mean several things one
thing it could be the that the heart is
not well oxygenated
and it could also be that the actual
electrical system of the heart is not
working well so it could be you I guess
in layman's terms it would be it could
be a short in the electrical wiring or
your borderline blowing a fuse or it
could also be a plumbing issue where the
oxygen and blood is not developing
enough nutrients as the lungs really
push on the heart one thing your
physician might do is they might ask you
to take a deep breath in hold it and
then listen to the different areas of
your heart see if there's any murmurs or
clicks on the valve and then see where
the point of Maximum impulse or where
the it feels like your heart is really
beating out of your chest
and is this something that can be
improved is it like VO2 max where it's
kind of the same no matter what you do
it's really hard to elevate that like if
you really dial in your health can you
you know over time create a new
Benchmark for your HRV or everybody has
different natural set points for that
yeah you can certainly improve your
heart rate variability some of it just
has to do with the body habitus of your
mediastinum which is the area of the
chest that has the heart and other
auxiliary contents but you can
definitely improve your heart rate
variability interesting I mean the other
the other metric that's a more recent
add to the whoop is is metabolic rate
I'm curious do you know what they're
measuring specifically when they come up
with this number every day about where
you're at it has to be
somewhat accurate because I've had covet
twice and both times my metabolic rate
skyrocketed the day before I had any
symptoms so I was definitely reading
something that I'm not consciously aware
of or experiencing
I don't know the exact parameters that
it tracks
but I assume that it tracks uh part of
this is just your Baseline resting heart
rate so if that is increased then the
heart is a muscle as well it requires
more
nutrients or more metabolism more
mitochondrial activity
as your heart rate increases right and
if you are fighting off an infection
there's an inflammatory response that's
going to require more of your heart
right yeah so that's how that is getting
into the calculus there yes right
interesting
um back on sleep for a minute uh
why is it that
sleep becomes so much more elusive as we
age you know as a young person you can
just fall asleep anywhere sleep for 12
hours it's nothing but a thing right as
I get older I have to like exercise so
much sleep hygiene just to you know buy
a lottery ticket to get eight hours and
sometimes I get it and sometimes I don't
despite everything that I do I have to
assume there's a huge hormonal piece of
play here that has something to do with
you know declining levels or balances as
we get older yeah there's certainly a
lot to do with it one of the main
symptoms of menopause is also known as
Vaso motor symptoms of menopause and a
lot of that is related to your estrogen
if you replace a bioidentical estrogen
in those individuals often the Vaso
motor symptoms like the waking at night
the fast heart rate The Hot Flashes as
well will improve and in men with very
low estrogen they actually have they can
have very similar symptoms or men on
aromatase Inhibitors and again if you
optimize the estrogen again then those
symptoms will resolve so that's part of
the component a lot of it is also just
the amount of acetylcholine that is
around some neurodegenerative diseases
have huge depletions in a acetylcholine
and also depletions of dopamine dopamine
is also a neurotransmitter hormone kind
of combo that can be implicated in
disorders sleeping as well
four parkinsonian disease Parkinson's is
basically where a little area of the
brain called in the basal ganglia called
the substantia [ __ ] no longer
synthesizes dopamine you have almost a
complete loss
and before Parkinson's develops it is
very common to see restless legs or very
restless sleep and waking at night even
before it can be diagnosed before any
Tremor right so but for someone like
myself I feel like I'm relatively
healthy but I probably have some
imbalance or whatever that's making
sleep perhaps a little bit more
difficult than it should be
um you would you would perhaps say look
into acetylcholine or let's see what's
going on there maybe prescribe you and
you know a supplement that would enhance
that perhaps I'm also a fan of getting
uh you know a clinically validated
polysomnogram I do love wearable data
and I think that it is the future but if
there is a very dysregulated sleep
perhaps not in your case I have a very
low threshold for ordering sleep studies
because you don't know what you don't
know and if you find something then you
can more accurately come up with a good
long-term plan for the right
um typically people think when they
think of of sleep supplements that
aren't you know sleeping pills uh they
think of melatonin right but not a good
idea to be consistently taking melatonin
before any individual would take
melatonin which is a form of hormone
replacement therapy just like taking
vitamin D is also from a hormone
replacement therapy I would consider why
is it melatonin dysregulated perhaps
even look at a melatonin cycle which can
get turned off and on throughout the day
it's regulated through the pineal gland
which goes along the optic nerve so that
morning sunlight that hopefully most
people are getting can kind of help shut
down that pineal gland production of
melatonin melatonin is also produced by
tryptophan so ensuring that you have
adequate dietary intake as well
but if you just take melatonin it has
other Downstream hormonal effects for
example on the gonadotropins which can
have to do with estrogen and
testosterone release
so you want to think about the dose and
then everybody metabolizes it very
differently so there could be a huge
range in dose I'm not against
melatonin for some individuals but for
most individuals it's not a great idea
to try to optimize your sleep but
effective if you're you know flying to
Europe or something like that and you
have to try to deal with jet lag and
time change correct as like a temporary
thinking about that circadian rhythm
whether it's melatonin or cortisol you
want to take it from whatever time zone
and put it into a new time zone there
are sleep medications that work on
melatonin rameltion is the name of one
of them
that is essentially a different
melatonin I believe there's three
different receptors for melatonin and
the third melatonin receptor is the most
hormonally indicated and the remeltion
just works with the first two mt1 and
mt2 receptors so for some individuals
that are traveling very often I do a
prescription of romelton which is a
generic sleep medicine which does not
work very well unless you have what's
called like jet lag sleep syndrome yeah
but that's a prescription that's not an
over-the-counter correct supplement yeah
one thing that I discovered recently a
couple months ago
I began to notice that that when I eat
pistachios I get fatigued maybe you know
30 45 minutes later so I started eating
some before I go to bed yeah and then I
thought like this is actually pretty
effective like I so I Googled it and
there's some kind of active I don't
remember but there's something some
active ingredient in pistachios that is
working as a sleep enhancement aid for
myself do you are you familiar with this
is this ring true to you or I'm not sure
what active ingredient could be in there
another mechanism of action it could be
it could keep your triglycerides
slightly higher
which can stabilize your glucose so your
glucose and your triglycerides are your
two main energy sources so perhaps it
helps your trigs and glucose stabilize a
bit more as well yeah I don't know I
know it's working though yeah I keep I
keep a little bowl by my bedside anyway
I'll find out afterwards what's going on
there
um
okay let's let's move into uh
uh hormones most more specifically for
men and women when you when you think of
men and Hormone Health you know what are
men concerned about especially men as
they're getting older they're concerned
about virility they're concerned about
fertility hair loss
they're obsessed with testosterone right
I think testosterone is a therapeutic
that's probably I live in Los Angeles
I'm sure it's over prescribed here like
I know tons of guys my age that are on
it and swear by it but I'm not so sure
all those people are are appropriate
candidates for this so you know on the
subject of the kind of things that men
are concerned with with respect to
Hormone Health uh you know maybe we can
start with with uh you know virility and
testosterone and how you think about
this and maybe how we should be thinking
about it instead
testosterone of course has effects on
every system of the body
so you're not just thinking about
testosterone for lean body mass in fact
what some of the main criteria that many
clinicians including the aafp and many
large organizations they look at things
like libido or sexual function
or even metabolic parameters like
pre-diabetes if you give an individual
that is hypogonadal testosterone they
are less likely to have diabetes and
potentially less likely to have coronary
artery disease even though it worsens
lipid profiles so if you're thinking
about supplementing or getting a
prescription of testosterone or trt
you really need to check your bases on
every system of the body the you know
the adrenal system the renal system your
renin Angiotensin system which has to do
with blood pressure your iron balance
also your cholesterol and lipids
testosterone is an inducer of an enzyme
called HMG COA reductase so it does the
opposite thing that lipid medications
called statins do almonds actually kind
of do a more of a similar thing to lipid
medications and statins
so you're really thinking about its
effect on all systems in the body
balancing the benefits and detriments
and for many people
the benefits and detriments could be
fairly even but there's a third option
as well and that's naturally optimizing
and for most individuals the benefits of
naturally optimizing outweigh everything
else right but I just want to go on it
right it's just I mean I'm not speaking
for myself personally I think I think
there's a lot like I think what you said
is very well put by the way
um what I heard is it's very important
to find a practitioner who really
understands the interplay between all of
these systems because I think the
typical guy
is not
we're not so great about thinking about
the long-term risks like the guy is like
I want to feel like myself I want to
have energy I want to have libido I want
to be able to put on muscle mass and
feel strong in the gym and you know yeah
the down the line stuff you know is it
gonna is it gonna you know put me at
greater risk for heart disease all those
kinds of things I'll I'll deal with that
later like I just I need to feel like a
man right now right and without a
responsible practitioner to say slow
down here's what we're actually dealing
with or if you do this it's going to be
counterproductive to the goals that
you're seeking you know guys are just
gonna do it nonetheless and pay the
price later
yes and there is certainly an epidemic
of uh use both with physician
supervision and not of many different
types of androgens and people seek it
out for the benefit
and that is why a shared decision-making
process and an informed decision with
the help of your health care provider is
so important yeah
um and by the way there's no such thing
as just a hormone expert so if there's
an aesthetic clinic and I do some
Aesthetics as well it's it's probably
not the best place to get your hormone
advice maybe not there's always
exceptions in everything it depends
right but you really need to be an
expert in every organ system of the body
hematology lipidology Dermatology
there's going to be infertility as well
especially so perhaps
so you can't just be a hormone expert in
isolation you have to have a a broad
spectrum full spectrum approach
with respect to testosterone replacement
therapy is it true that once you go I
mean I assume if you go on it you're
signaling to your body that it doesn't
need to produce it anymore what is the
long-term implication of that like if
you go on trt and then you go off it
I'm sure there's a lapse of time before
your body gets the signal that it has to
start producing it again right so do you
just is it a life sentence like okay
once you go on this you have to stay on
it or you're going to have this lull in
which you're going to be sub-optimal 99
of individuals who go on trt can get
back their original function
but if you don't know what the original
function is like let's say one
individual started with a total T of 600
.
um two years later their total T may
have decreased to 550 just due to aging
but individual two has a total
testosterone of 100.
and they're not going to gain function
because they're not guaranteed to gain
better function than they had in the
first place right so that's obviously
the better candidate for the
intervention yes yeah and if you do go
off it how long is that period of time
before the body resets to Baseline
usually two to twelve months it can
depend on the type of Ester that you're
on so if you're on an ester like
undecanoate which is very very rarely
prescribed by the way then it can take
months and months just to clear the
amount of testosterone that has not been
it has not had esteresis cleave that
Ester which is what for injectable
testosterone that helps obviously for
like pellets or gels it's different but
a general rule of thumb is two to six
months for most two to twelve months
otherwise
not everyone needs drugs or medications
like HCG in order to restore function
but if there is a significant degree of
testicular atrophy
they get more and more helpful with the
degree of testicular atrophy right and
on the subject of of hair loss uh how
how related to hormone dysregulation is
that versus genetic presets what are
possible interventions uh that can be
explored for ameliorating hair loss or I
don't know even maybe reversing it like
this is something that you know a lot of
guys are super interested in for
individuals with hair loss or just for
an individual who wants an improved
quality of hair you're thinking about uh
is it androgenic alopecia so is it
related to the activity of that Androgen
receptor
or is it some other sort of effluvium
there's a lot of different types of
telogen effluvium related to low iron or
related to poor thyroid function or even
related to infection and illness
and once you figure out which category
that's in addressing what is the cause
so assuming in this case that it's
androgenic or androgenetic alopecia
each individual has a genetic threshold
of activity at the Androgen receptor you
don't necessarily know that until you
start to have miniaturization and loss
of hair
usually if a hair becomes smaller and
smaller and smaller and it's hard to
tell without a magnifying glass but as
it becomes smaller then eventually the
stem cell will leave the scalp and the
follicle will be permanently dead rather
than the normal cycle where you have
antigen phase catagen phase telogen
phase and then it kind of dies and is
reincarnated so
making sure that your androgenic load is
not above that threshold is the best way
for men and some women have androgenic
alopecia as well
that's the best way to make sure that
you're not going to have a permanent
loss of that follicle and how do you
test for that
you can do a lot of different tests but
because all androgens buying that same
Androgen receptor again there's only one
Androgen receptor men have one copy
because it's on the X chromosome women
have two copies
you can look at DHT which is
dihydrotestosterone that's the strongest
Androgen it is you know all androgens
cause hair loss through the action of
the Androgen receptor
um the higher your free DHT the more it
will be binding
you can also check a testosterone and a
DHEA sulfate and an estradiol which is
your main estrogen you want to make sure
you have enough estrogen and that'll
also tell you how much testosterone is
converting to estrogen right okay got it
and then the intervention would be what
finding a protocol that is the most
highly tolerable with the least side
effects
that will
take that patient and take their
androgenic load below that threshold so
that not only do they not have further
miniaturization and loss but hopefully
those miniaturized hairs or the
follicles that are in between deciding
whether or not they're going to
permanently die or enter antigen phase
again hopefully all those come back so
you can somewhat experience some
regrowth in those situations and in the
you know Pantheon of hair loss patients
like how what is the percentage of
candidates who fit into the category
where that would be beneficial
most female patients do not require
pharmacologic intervention most male
patients that are predisposed and you
can also check your genes to see not
only how prone are you to overly
sensitive Androgen receptors in the
scalp you can also check the sensitivity
of your Androgen receptor as well it's a
CAG repeat disease almost kind of like
Huntington's disease but on your
Androgen receptor which is another
tangent which I don't think we need to
get into today but depending on how
sensitive you are often pharmacology is
required for a male that does not want
to lose the hair so then it's a balance
of it's really
a shared decision that you make how
important is it related to the potential
side effects of an intervention the
intervention might include topical or
even oral five Alpha reductase
Inhibitors that just decreases DHT it
also might include topical and High
androgens like Ketoconazole or
for women you can also do topical
spironolactone although it is absorbed
you can also do topical caffeine and
there's also new medications one of the
most interesting ones is topical class
coderone
which is a kind of sort of a Psalm but
it's a it decreases the activity of the
Androgen receptor through binding to it
to crowd off all androgens so not just
DHT but also testosterone wow and what
are those uh potential side effects that
you mentioned
if any anti-androgen goes systemic
you're looking at a lot of things you're
looking at your ratio of testosterone to
estrogen for example for a 5-alpha
reductase inhibitor it will increase
estradiol or estrogens by about 10
percent
so you want to make sure that that
estrogen is not already teetering on the
borderline you're also looking at your
progestogens so just like testosterone
converts to DHT progesterone converts to
dhp which is the progestogen that
crosses the blood-brain barrier and
helps you have some of those relaxing
side effects so you're also looking at
that and then last you're just looking
at the actual level of Androgen so if
there's an individual who has a very low
testosterone but a mid-normal DHT it is
a very poor idea to put them on a five
Alpha reductase number wow I think I
understood about I don't know maybe 30
percent of that but I get the gist of it
um and and mainly you know I'm
encouraged like there does seem to be so
many more effective therapies for this
like when I was younger it was just sort
of like if you start you know you're out
of luck like there's not much that can
be done and whatever
protocols or therapies were available
everybody kind of knew they weren't
really that effective but it sounds like
that's changed quite a bit absolutely
and one thing that I should mention that
has changed even within the last year or
two is our understanding of five Alpha
reductase Inhibitors which again are
kind of the most common
um androgenic alopecia meds one is
called finasteride
and that only inhibits two of the three
enzymes a particular note finasteride
inhibits the enzyme that is in genital
skin but not the enzyme that is in your
other skin so you could extrapolate from
that it causes of many different side
effects from other five afro ductase
Inhibitors wow interesting
um fun fact also you used to cut and
color hair yeah
you were a hair stylist yeah essentially
um I made a very very little money from
it yeah but this is part of your
homeschooling yeah I suppose so
um but yeah for quite some time and I I
still cut the hair for many of my
friends and a couple of my patients as
well uh-huh but full service yeah
there's a lot to the same look good feel
good uh-huh yeah for sure right
um cool well well what are other some of
the common
um male hormonal interventions
um that are important to talk about I
mean we could talk about PRP peptides
placenta stem cell therapy I have some
experience with this I've had some
chronic lower back problems and I've had
some interventions with that with uh
with peptides and and PRP and the like
so I know a little bit about that
um it's been an interesting kind of
Journey with all of that but you know
talk a little bit about that world
peptides of course are medications I
think of them as several different
classes one class I kind of consider the
pseudo PRP class and that would include
thymus and beta 4 or tb500 bpc157
and probably ghk copper peptide as well
and there's of course others but those
will either help with growth factors
which is most of them or angiogenesis
which is new blood vessels
kind of help taking it's very similar to
PRP one of the main uh components of PRP
is vegf which is actually a cytokine
and if you have a higher level of vegf
then you're going to have more healing
of tissues that are not well
vascularized so tissues that don't have
good blood flow like a lot of tendons
and ligaments can need more of this new
blood vessel formation or vegf activity
in order to heal yeah and effective very
effective in that regard yeah yep likely
only a matter of time until
those have patented approvals I think
that the presence of PRP has kind of
delayed the Medical Science when it
comes to those because PRP does many of
the same things
and one of the benefits of peptides is
you don't necessarily have you don't
want to inject it ever into a ligament
or a tendon of course all these should
be under the supervision of a physician
but
um some people can be trained to use
these at home just like some people that
are on trt or growth hormone replacement
can be trained at home as well right you
mean to do your own home injections and
stuff like that yeah for some people
it's feasible yeah and and what do you
know about the emerging science around
placenta stem cell therapy like this is
like wild stuff
yeah um the earlier the stem cell is
taken so for example from a placenta or
from the umbilical cord the more potency
it has so you have like pluripotent
versus multipotent so that's why
um stem cell banking is something that
each individual should consider
um we actually chose not to Stem Cell
bank with my one-year-old or my
two-year-old perhaps my decision will
change in the future it is something
that is emerging and theoretically it
can help cure a lot of diseases
um some people have heard of you know a
family that had a baby
specifically just to help cure like a
rare bone cancer or whatnot so a lot of
this
um stem cell transplant or stem cell
therapy can help with severe diseases
but it can also help with less severe
diseases as well it's only a matter of
time until the technology catches up and
we have no idea when it will yeah it
seems to be accelerating though quite a
bit it's interesting that you didn't
that you didn't Bank cells from your
kids what was the rationale for that
it can be relatively expensive and
uh I am not a hundred percent convinced
that it will be clinically significant
for individuals that do not have a rare
disease
so for for example uh using stem cell
therapy for a joint or a ligament
healing I think there will be excellent
alternatives to that whether it's PRP or
peptides I think that there's going to
be
you know I don't think that in most
cases stem cells will be the only thing
that you can do unless you're trying to
get a stem cell transplant for like a
rare hematologic disease right right so
it's not
necessary that you would need your own
genetic code in those interventions in
which case the importance of of banking
your your children's stem cells become
less important correct but 50 years from
now who knows man it is a long time it's
a tough decision
um and what makes it tougher is that
often the individual is making that
decision are very early on in their life
when they are not as financially stable
so the opportunity cost for that is
pretty high as well yeah exactly same
thing with uh freezing uh eggs or child
storage for sperm yeah yeah yeah I want
to turn to female hormone Health
specifically in a minute but you know on
the subject of stem cells I can't help
but think about
um what's going on in longevity science
and anti-aging science and I just I have
to ask you kind of where are your heads
at in terms of
um
some of the science out there like what
is the path that we are are we on like
are we out over our skis when we're
starting to talk about nmn and NAD and
all this kind of stuff like I'm trying
to get a sense of of what's real and and
what you know maybe in the near or
distant future my sense is that it's
really cool to talk about all these
things and think about them but in terms
of their immediate practicality and
applicability in our lives like not so
sure right so where is your head with
all of that
so interventions anti-aging
interventions we could talk about uh
like mitochondrial or growth agonists
nmn NR even NAD ion patches or NAD
infusions and rapamycin correct
um rapamycin is a little different
correct so that works on mtor so mtor's
mammalian Target of rapamyosin and I
think that has amazing promise as well
and it is currently clinically
applicable as is inimin as is metformin
metformin has three main effects that I
think of its effect on shpg it might it
likely bumps your shpg up just a bit
partly due to its action on insulin
igf-1 and igf binding peptide one which
is the protein that binds up igf-1 which
is kind of like think of it as your
growth hormone long term
and then also it works on your glucose
and insulin
so for an individual that has insulin
resistance metformin is a amazing
anti-aging intervention or for someone
who is just had has one of those things
that are off you can Target that
specifically to intervene same for mtor
so let's say there's someone that is
huge into intermittent fasting and they
have great fasting they don't have very
much cancer history they're not worried
about cell senescence as much
um which is kind of like zombie cells if
you will
pre-cancerous cells they're probably not
as good at a can for rapamycin but if
there's someone on a very high protein
diet a lot of proteins like
um branched chain amino acids will
activate mtor
so they might be a better candidate for
rapamycin especially if they have a
family history of cancers that
um can likely be prevented with it now
it's all still theoretical but it is a
very well tolerated medication
with edamin there might be such a thing
as too high a dose of an inamin it might
be difficult to get because if you're
not consuming it with fat perhaps it's
not absorbed as well
and also the I don't think the debate is
over about like the absorption of nmn
compared to even NAD getting inside the
cell getting into the mitochondria where
CoQ10 can convert it to ATP
so I don't mean to be overly verbose the
the thousand foot view is each of those
is clinically applicable but some
individuals benefit far more from others
like any growth Agonist whether it's
growth hormone or a growth hormone
releasing peptide or nmn if you have a
very very high dose then theoretically
it can cause increased cell overturn and
cell growth which can be uh potentially
linked with cancer cancer is the big
thing to worry about with that obviously
right so you don't play around
personally with any of these protocols
I actually do yeah I don't think it
would be harmful to most of course what
I do is not what everybody should do but
every two weeks I take rapamycin and I
alternate days between uh nicotinamide
riboside which is NR and inamin which is
a nicotinamide mononucleotide
and I usually stay around a dose of 250
to 500 milligrams of in a minute NR and
again I don't think necessarily anybody
should do this cancer does run fairly
strong in the family both uh especially
like the hormonal cancers like prostate
cancer and breast cancer
I do take Metformin only with my
rapamycin yeah so I obviously I think
it's a full protocol I think it's
clinically applicable yeah that's super
interesting do you notice is there any
kind of lived experience difference as a
result of taking it or is it just
something that's in the background doing
whatever it's doing unnoticeable to you
that I know ever haven't developed
cancer yet yeah and hopefully I wouldn't
have either even if I hadn't taken it
but no deleterious side effects right
and no but no like noticeable energy
boost or anything like that
um not from taking those I also take
ubiquinol which is the active form of
CoQ10
again thinking about nmn and NAD
precursors in general if you're on
inamin the rate limiting step is likely
not in a d Plus for your energy
many power lifters and other athletes
take ubiquinol which is the again the
active form of CoQ10 to help with energy
just like if you're fueling up a race
car you can't just keep giving it more
fuel and expect it to function at some
point the lack of fuel is not the rate
limiting step it's the fuel pump which
is L-Carnitine or the converting enzyme
which I suppose could be seen as octane
booster or the backup fuel tank which
could be seen as creatine right
um I could be wrong but I I seem to
recall that Peter attia
talked about his experience of being on
Metformin and I think he did it for
quite a while but ultimately
um got off it because he felt like as an
athlete he couldn't hit his top end
right there was some kind of energy
limiter on it that was you know
problematic for him it likely goes back
to metformin's three main effects if
you're taking metformin one evening
every two weeks it's very unlikely to
have a significant effect on those
parameters but it can help or it can
decrease your active or free igf-1 just
like you have a free testosterone you
have a free igf one so it both increases
the igf binding peptide 1 and decreases
igf-1
so if you're already sub-optimal when it
comes to growth hormone or igf-1 that
could certainly affect your performance
if your free testosterone and free
androgens are relatively low then
metformin can also slightly decrease
your free testosterone because again it
increases shbg
and then also a lot of athletes are
hypersensitive to peptides and
bodybuilders are this way as well they
know them as peptide guys where
something that will increase their
insulin of course some bodybuilders do
take insulin but in general if something
increases your insulin and growth
hormone and igf-1 that can certainly be
performance enhancing and Metformin will
decrease all three of those yeah so it
kind of depends on what your Baseline is
yeah interesting
um that's wild man wow uh
very very interesting I let's let's turn
to women's hormone health for a little
bit
um you know conversely from men who are
obsessed about testosterone and virility
and you know what we just talked about
you know from a women's perspective I
suspect their concerns uh you know
Orient around fertility uh you know what
happens with menopause and the focus
being on estrogen and maybe progesterone
progesterone right so talk me through
kind of how you think about women's
health and Hormone Health specifically
and
um what women should be thinking about
women obviously have a unique decision
to make when it comes to Hormone Health
because every woman will inevitably go
through at least with current technology
we'll go through ovarian failure also
known as menopause
there are many things that can likely
prolong this the health and the
production of both like the ovulation
from the ovary and the production of
hormones from the ovary
but when you're thinking about Hormone
Health for women you think about it
actually very similarly to men
where they just have a little bit less
testosterone so maybe one less let's say
that uh Rooks and knights and Bishops or
testosterone and the only difference
between the chessboard of men and women
is women have maybe one more Queen and
one less Knight but they still have
three to four times as much testosterone
and they still have a high amount of
pons or DHEA
women that go through adrenal pause
which is where they have a decreased
DHEA at the same time as menopause have
in general have particularly severe
symptoms
the decrease in estrogen whether it's
estrogen made from the ovary or estrogen
made peripherally from DHEA
is related to more plaque buildup in the
arteries we know that women that go
through an early menopause called POI or
premature ovarian insufficiency have a
very high rate of plaque in the
coronaries and also a higher rate of
osteoporosis um
so addressing these things
by getting a baseline lab before your
menopausal or even before your
perimenopausal is very important right
so let's say somebody comes into you in
the midst of it though they're
experiencing this kind of symptomology
what is like the kind of holistic
intervention to
you know as best as you can you know
course correct the imbalance and you
know ameliorate at least some of the
more severe symptomology
optimize adrenal hormones if there is
something that's related to for example
uh testosterone production
the thika cells of the ovary also cease
to function in menopause which gives you
almost half of your testosterone
um but uh ensuring that your adrenal
production is as good as possible is the
first step that's kind of uh Nature's
mechanism to account for menopausal
changes is that the adrenals will be
back up
so the better your adrenals can function
the less symptoms you have and the less
likely you are to need urgent hormone
replacement however that being said if
you are an individual that benefits more
from hormone replacement a female that
does the earlier you start it right
after menopause the better
and when it comes to some of the
diseases that we see with women like
PCOS or endometriosis and fibroids you
know walk me through obviously these are
all different things but like the
relationship between Hormone Health and
the incidence of these types of ailments
a lot of them come down to imbalances in
not only estrogen but also androgens
progestogens and growth hormone and
igf-1
many individuals have excess signaling
of growth hormone and that not only
theoretically increases the growth of
endometrial tissue regardless of the
endometrial tissue is in the uterus it's
the tissue that lines the uterus or if
it's outside that's known as
endometriosis then if you give someone
growth hormone then the endometriosis
will get worse things like diabetes
especially type 1 diabetes precipitously
increased growth hormone that's the
reason why those individuals are more
prone to cancers as well
so you want to have optimal growth
hormone signaling theoretically
something like metformin would actually
potentially help
for endometriosis but you have to
address everything else if there's an
estrogen dominance you have to of course
address that as well right because that
will also grow endometrial tissue or can
lead to adenomyosis or it can lead to
anovulatory Cycles but theoretically if
a patient comes to you prior to
succumbing to any of these and you're
able to work with that patient balance
their hormones out look at all their
blood panels and everything and kind of
sort everything out you potentially
sidestep not only these diseases but the
severity of the symptomology incident to
menopause when it arises
like that's the power of like Hormone
Health really correct yeah and keeping
in mind the individual needs for a
patient a patient that has PCOS and also
really high adrenal hormone production
might be more resilient to menopause and
the less likely to need HRT so there can
be benefits
um a lot of genetic polymorphisms or
variables there's a benefit to it
historically even uh hyper coagulability
disorders can be productive against
postpartum Hemorrhage yeah
well which is not as much of a deal now
as it was 100 or 200 years ago right but
keeping in mind the needs of a patients
that's more true preventative medicine
you were mentioning Primary Care versus
secondary versus tertiary
that's trying to have true primary care
and hopefully I think eventually we will
have a widespread care that is available
to many that is even before primary
where you get not only your baseline lab
panel hopefully at age 18 or even before
just like a new car off the assembly
line you get your full genome sequenced
and we can soon make clinically
applicable decisions from that as well
yeah I mean I feel like that's the
direction of the technology of
healthcare and telemedicine and
wearables like we're going to have these
massive data sets and we're going to be
getting you know information in real
time that is getting transmitted
directly to our practitioner who is
actually qualified to analyze the data
and make conclusions from that like
we're not there yet I feel like most of
healthcare is living in a completely
different era where they're faxing
things back and forth you know it's like
it's ridiculous based on you know the
technology of 2022 but hopefully you
know that's where we're headed and
that's how you can really
um
not only practice true primary care
because you're seeing things before they
happen and addressing them before they
become
truly problematic
um but also it feels like that's going
to create its own business model that's
going to make it of more viable and
easier career path for the Young Medical
practitioner coming right out of school
yeah speaking of that there is an odd
cognitive dissonance between the
individuals who seek out Primary Care
they usually do it because they're not
able to get into another specialty some
schools like the University of Kansas do
emphasize primary care and have special
programs to incentivize it but it
doesn't make a lot of sense to take the
most complicated widest scope of
medicine and in general put applicants
that are not able to get into any other
Specialties to do that so how is that
you know how would that be best
addressed you know at the medical school
level that's a really difficult question
to answer probably not at the medical
school level
um
there are many people that go into
medicine with altruistic
um motives but I was Pro I was told at
least a hundred times throughout medical
school not to do Primary Care
specifically do not go to a Family
Medicine Residency and this was at a
medical school that emphasized primary
care because like you're not going to be
able to make a living or that's not as
well respected what was the rationale
those two reasons are often cited and
also that it's just a poor lifestyle
because you turn into a referral robot
or an algorithm follower right basically
you get these tiny Windows to see
patients and in order for it to make
economic sense it's a churn and burn
kind of thing right that's why that's
part of the reason why burnout is
extremely high is one people are in
primary care and it wasn't their
preferred specialty and their Heart's
Not really in it and then two because
even if they did learn to love it
they're so limited by not just insurance
companies but what the patient is
willing to do that they don't really
feel like they're helping people right
so if you were in a position to overhaul
the you know medical education
establishment like where would you begin
like would you just burn it down and
rebuild it or what kinds of curriculums
or programs would you you like to see
you know become part and parcel of the
experience of the medical student to
best train doctors for this new era and
to be able to treat patients
holistically
think part of the process has been
getting better there's a examination
called step one and I believe now it's
pass fail and that's largely not based
on clinical knowledge it's based on
scientific or Niche knowledge which I
loved and really enjoyed but many people
feel like that holds them back because
they get a poor score on that but it
does not have a lot to do with how
Adept of a practitioner they will be so
that's probably a positive change a lot
of people are also going to systems
based or like
case-based education so not necessarily
modules here and there but they're
trying to get people into more
clinically relevant positions
um and I think that's a positive change
for education but I think a lot of the
changes would have to be systematic
whether that involves uh single-payer I
think one change that has really helped
emphasize uh medical students going into
Primary Care is direct Primary Care also
known as DPC we actually had several
different recent graduates at the
University of Kansas come and speak to
our medical school about how they're
helping the underserved uninsured and
underinsured community and they're
making a a good solid living doing
direct Primary Care helping people that
the system normally doesn't help and I
think that is probably helping more than
anything else yeah that's super
interesting but purely from a a
philosophical point of view like my
understanding of medical education is
that it's predominated by
uh studying disease and how to treat
disease it's not about like how to
optimize Wellness right like yeah like
that's just I mean just talk about
systemically like it's just a different
you know like that's what it's about
right and so
you don't necessarily uh graduate from
medical school with an understanding or
a tool kit for how to promote optimal
well-being in people you just know how
to treat diseases as they come I mean am
I being unfair like a
no I think that's certainly true
um there are new fellowships that are
um coming up for example lifestyle
medicine fellowships or perhaps even the
Obesity medicine Fellowship you can make
a case for
but there are new fellowships and board
certifications that can that can likely
help address this
um
teaching more and more Health
optimization or individualized medicine
at the academic level or in medical
schools will likely help as well
but if there's not a depending on the
market for it I think that those two
things would have to go hand in hand
which is changing education and also
um just the
economics or the supply and demand of
the system sure right and so
extrapolating on how you would change
the medical education industrial complex
let's now fantasize that you have become
the Surgeon General of the United States
in charge of Health Care policy like
what kind of you know Global systemic
changes would you like to see that would
make this a more optimally functioning
system that's truly serving patients
yeah so it should a Surgeon General I
think in the last uh even a decade there
have been many different good changes
for example obesity is considered an
epidemic I think that was a wonderful
decision there's also a program called
healthy people 2030. and many of the
goals of healthy people 2030 is to
decrease the incidence and prevalence of
certain diseases for example
pre-diabetes
and the uh I guess the actionable item
for change in order to decrease this is
test and treat or screen and treat so
more screening for A1C I would have
loved if they had added fasting insulin
or even a glucose tolerance test to that
but more screening for A1C more
screening for fasting glucose
um and earlier screening correct yep
there's also goals for childhood obesity
and actionable items in order to achieve
these but there is not very widespread
application of this many of these are
not included in what's called meaningful
use or mips it's called mips criteria
now mips
and the hinge of that that sways is if
you do not fulfill these then you will
not get your extra reimbursement from
insurance so inside the insurance model
um there are certain things that are
looked at as more or less important for
example a Statin in a diabetic
yeah and when you look at the incidence
of type 2 diabetes and pre-diabetes and
what's being projected in the coming
decades I mean there never has been an
epidemic of such proportions I think
they're looking at something like 50 of
40 to 50 percent of the population will
be suffering along the spectrum of this
metabolic disorder right so you know to
the extent that we can test for it early
and develop lifestyle protocol
interventions as early as possible it's
not only in the best interest of the
patient it's in the best interest of the
economy and the Health Care system in
order to do that because otherwise we're
looking at some kind of you know
economic bankrupting disaster like how
are we going to manage all of this
yeah not a lot of tertiary care yeah I
mean it's just economically impossible
um a lot of primary care
um one interesting thing uh you
mentioned that it's happening earlier
and earlier the New England Journal of
Medicine did a study uh an
epidemiological study that's probably a
retrospective cohort basically looking
at groups of people and as they
progressed throughout their childhood
and Adolescence
and we used to think that many people
would uh grow out of their fat phase so
during puberty they would
um you know kind of thin out and their
BMI does change but if you look at what
happens throughout their life
if you look at kids over the age of five
up to puberty if they have a a high
percentile a high class of obesity it's
not done by BMI in kids it's done by
percentile so if they're in a high
percentile before they almost always
return to a high class of obesity after
puberty a lot of people see this
anecdotally because after puberty you
have a couple years that you're kind of
catching up on and then during your last
year of high school or first couple
years of college then those individuals
were re-enter obesity so it does not
appear that you really grow out now it's
certainly a chance to change your
lifestyle
but a lot of this epidemic comes from a
cultural standpoint because the the
family
teaches the same lifestyle habits to
their kids that they're doing yeah sure
so on that subject matter how are you so
you have two young kids right I assume
these kids are going to be homeschooled
right they're going to be growing food
and you know undergoing the same
academic you know protocol that you did
is that the plan yeah absolutely for
their ages they are a huge help in the
garden and the two-year-old even picks
up the chickens and collects the eggs
and everything yeah so they're a huge
help especially for their age
um definitely being outdoors I don't
think they necessarily need to be need
to be homeschooled all the way through
but I would certainly plan on it I think
that it helps
um
it's not as regimented it helps create a
unique individual and I think that's a
lot of the strength of an Eclectic
Society is that people have different
ideas rather than just being taught the
same thing I think that it could be done
in schools but that's certainly our plan
for that right and is it do you have a
specific homeschooling protocol is it
unschooling is it like a rigorous
academic you know curriculum like how
does it look how did it look for you and
what do you envisioned for your kids
growing up I did about every
homeschooled curriculum that there was
and perhaps that was for the best I did
University model stuff I did tapestra
Grace abeka
um all there's a whole bunch of
different ones and I think that kind of
helped me because I would have lost
interest if it was the same thing
and for them uh they're two and a half
and one so they haven't really started a
lot of school yet but uh I do like the
Montessori model I think that is great
especially for young kids my wife is
speech language pathologist and she
taught in early childhood for a while as
well and she's also a fan of a mostly
montessori-based model unschooling is an
interesting standpoint but I think just
like there's an optimal
Health protocol for each individual for
each kid there's an optimal protocol
some kids do fantastic in a Traditional
School model and some kids do well in
kind of like the antithesis of that the
unschooling model
uh
in this area I think that just because
the thesis isn't true it doesn't mean
that the antithesis isn't true so I A
lot of people are like well you know all
school is bad everyone should be
homeschooled or nobody should be
homeschooled
um there it's too much dependent on the
parent and not the society so the truth
is probably somewhere else right so if
you're going to practice personalized
medicine you're going to practice
personalized Academia yeah yeah right
definitely and so maybe it would be good
to just share a little bit of insight
for the parents or young parents out
there or parents of young children out
there who are trying to set their kids
up for Success not necessarily
academically but in terms of Lifestyle
habits healthy habits
um you know with Hormone Health in mind
of course but
um but you know with with obviously the
intent being to sidestep all of these uh
you know terrible lifestyle illnesses
that are debilitating all too many
people
A good rule of thumb is try to eat at
least one meal a day one meal a day as a
family
don't have any Electronics or screens
around when you do so
try to have one movement past time
that'll last a lifetime that you can do
with your family whether it's taking
walks or whether it's doing chores on
the farm or whatnot try to have at least
one of those things and then on a if not
a day-to-day basis at least a few times
a week regardless of what your kids do
for academic education try to teach them
something to pass it along as well even
if it's cultural a lot of people will um
you know not pass along whether it's a
language or whether it's um just
cultural knowledge that will not get
passed along to Future generations and
that is one thing that has been lost a
lot for example some parents are great
at gardening and they don't pass that
along some parents are great at music
and they don't pass that along so
passing along that gift of knowledge is
super important yeah that's beautiful I
I haven't heard anyone articulate that
but I would agree with you
wholeheartedly that's that's beautifully
put and solid advice my friend I think
the last thing I want to uh just kind of
quickly get into is is some counsel for
for the average person out there who
doesn't live in Kansas and is not going
to be able to come and see you and is
thinking how do I find a Kyle Gillette
in my area like are there resources
available like where do you point people
uh to find out more about how they can
identify a holistic health practitioner
functional medicine doctor and even if
there isn't someone in their area
perhaps some resources that would be
valuable and helpful
yeah
um there are obviously many good doctors
out there even in traditional health
clinics
just like if you're searching for a
mechanic or someone to fix your fence or
whatnot
it is totally okay to read profiles and
reviews of healthcare providers online
I would emphasize for the for the
average person at least try to have a
nurse practitioner or PA or MD or do
that they see if they have someone like
a DC or an indie as part of their
Healthcare providing team or dietitian
whatnot or a health coach and that is
also okay but they would just kind of be
part of the team if they're specifically
looking for obesity medicine advice as
many people are then looking for a
doctor that is board certified in
obesity Medicine of which there are tons
all around A-bomb is the certifying
organization American Board of obesity
medicine
that is also a great place to start
that's good and if somebody uh wants to
get a blood panel or let's just assume
maybe there isn't an obesity medicine
specialist in their area or there isn't
a Doctor Who's sophisticated in Hormone
Health but this you know uh excited
individual wants to get a picture of
their Hormone Health like uh you know
maybe they could tell their doctor like
I want to make sure that we test for
these things or whatever like to the
extent that they can shoulder
responsibility for their health and you
know be a little bit more you know
active and have some agency in this
relationship
for that individual I would uh advise
them to be brutally honest even down to
the tiniest little niche if they feel
like their energy or Focus or libido or
athletic performance is even a little
bit off or their sleep then tell the
healthcare provider that and tell them
that they would like diagnostic Labs
specifically to look for that the
healthcare provider could potentially
use those changes even if they're not
severe even if they're let's say
moderate they can still use that as a
code to where potentially the insurance
might cover it however conversely
fortunately there's many different
services that
patients can use to get their labs done
without having to go through insurance I
would venture to say for 90 of people
they're just best off not even bothering
with insurance especially if they don't
have anything if they're looking for a
true Baseline panel then your insurance
is very unlikely to cover it it's not
going to cover looking for another
service to cover for that at some point
I will post my recommended lab panels at
gillettehealth.com
but it's perfectly fine to shop around
for labs just like you shop around for
everything else yeah cool
meanwhile uh you are practicing in
Kansas the Gillette Health Clinic people
can come and see you if they want to
travel to Kansas right so they can go to
your website uh contact you if they're
interested in that
correct uh they can go to
gillettehealth.com and it tells a lot
about our in-person options and also our
telemedicine options
for many individuals that you just
described I would consider that
individual underserved I recently wrote
an article that was published in the MSL
journal with my friend Alec McCarthy
about the role of tele of medical
Affairs in telemedicine basically the
balance between
on one hand yes in-person medicine is
always better than telemedicine but on
the other hand telemedicine is a whole
lot better than nothing and a lot of
individuals that we see via our
telemedicine let's say maybe this person
sees this one time in person and then
after that almost all their follow-ups
are telemedicine or things like lab
reviews or even meeting the patient
seeing if they're a good fit
telemedicine can be a wonderful option
for that yeah very cool and uh if people
want to learn more about you they can
listen to your podcast the Gillette
Health podcast you've done you've done a
couple not a ton of it did you just
start it or did you just do it
intermittently it's brand new we're
trying to figure it out but we do plan
on talking a lot more and bringing a lot
more content that is applicable that is
an actionable item to the public we kind
of do every other one we do one where we
just go way down the rabbit hole that's
very Niche and then we do one that's
kind of in layman's terms right cool
yeah I enjoy it check that out I did say
at the outside of this podcast that we
were going to kind of get into
supplements we didn't do so much of that
like there was a million things I wanted
to talk to you about that we didn't get
to but you and Andrew huberman did a
great job of that was a very supplement
Centric conversation that went on for at
least two and a half hours so people can
check that out I I don't know that I
could do any better than you guys did on
that regard
um and uh that's it man I think that's
it for today I just wanted to kind of
end it by
um by saluting you I think it's really
cool what you're doing I think it's
important work and and and I really
think that you are
um
a model of the future and a role model
for future doctors and uh I I really
appreciate you coming here and and
sharing time space with me and and the
audience man and I'm at your service if
there's anything I can ever do to
support you or help help you out thank
you it's an honor and a pleasure yeah
cool
um
Instagram also drop your Instagram yeah
you you do a lot of cool stuff on
Instagram Instagram is definitely my
main Hub it is Kyle Gillette MD and
Gillette Health on all other platforms
yeah right on man and and always welcome
to come back here there's plenty other
stuff I could talk to you about and uh
it was really cool man so thank you
thanks peace yeah
thank you
[Music]